Yesterday, Saturday and Monday!
Today, Saturday and Monday!
trains instance
C
an
So Leute, ehm, wir sind am Start, MonkaS ist auch da und Poggers ist auch da, der allerdings
neuerdings Poggy heißt, so beste Option noch, noch Confirm einfach, ja, YOLO, so Moment,
einfach eine Rolle mal Kirby Musik aus, was hatten wir gestern an das da, oh ne da wird
gesungen, das geht nicht, dann lieber irgendwas wo nicht gesungen wird, ja also Leute, es war
ja Poggy mit GGY, es war heute geplant, dass wir uns den neuen Westpacify angucken, der ist
allerdings noch nicht da, laut DHL ist er in Zustellung, aber immer noch nicht eingetroffen
und also wenn ich mal so von meinen Erfahrungen mit DHL ausgehe, wenn er bis 18.23 Uhr noch
nicht eingetroffen ist, dann trifft er heute wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr ein, deswegen
müssen wir uns überlegen, was wir machen könnten, ich hab mir ein paar Sachen, ein paar Sachen
überlegt, was wir machen können, aber ich warte erst noch mal bis alle da sind, welche
Konsole benutze ich, das ist Gnome Terminal mit Base 16 Tomorrow Night 256 Theme, TMX drin
mit ZSH und alles, im Prinzip bei ganzen Themes hab ich Base 16 Tomorrow Night, bei dir hat
DHL mal um 21.30 Uhr geklingelt, ich wär froh, wenn das noch kommt, der Boss ist back, mir
gehts gut, wie gehts denn dem Boss, wie gehts der Asus Rockkappe, ja ich bin begeistert,
Asus ist tatsächlich sogar drauf eingegangen, haben gesagt, schicken wir ne neue Kappe,
da ist echt sehr nett von Asus, die man ja Asus nennt und nicht Asus und auch nicht
Asus, ergeblich hat er von Asus mal erzählt, dass die Amis ganz gerne Asus sagen und das
triggert die immer, was war Asus, Korea, Japan, Taiwan, stimmt, Taiwan, genau, Asus heißt
Asus, 33 Grad unter dem Dach, ich kann dir nur empfehlen eine Klimaanlage dir anzuschaffen,
ich hab mir auch ne Klimaanlage angeschafft und seitdem ist das deutlich angenehmer, 25
Grad, dazu kann ich nur sagen, kann er mal updaten hier, was macht denn der da so ewig,
Klimaanlage ist tatsächlich sehr, und vor allem auch sehr, also Klimaanlage ist wirklich
praktisch, Klimaanlage kostet ja nix, tatsächlich so teuer wie man denkt, ist das gar nicht,
ich hab ne masslos oversized Anlage genommen, wo ich theoretisch noch bis zu 3 Räume mehr
anschließen könnte und ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, was es gekostet hat, ich glaube,
ich sag jetzt einfach mal irgendwas 1500 oder so oder 2000, irgendwie so in dem Dreh,
es ist auf jeden Fall für das, was man bekommt und das, was es an Ausstattung dann im Endeffekt
bietet, ist es gar nicht so schlimm, wie ich gedacht hab, ich hab eigentlich gedacht,
ich muss da jetzt 5k oder so hinlegen, aber es war deutlich drunter, nicht mal die Hälfte,
wieviel Räume hab ich abgedeckt, ich hab aktuell nur Arbeitszimmer und Schlafzimmer
dran, das sind halt auch die Räume, die direkt an der Wand sind, wo die Klimaanlage ist,
ich hab ne Klimaanlage von Mitsubishi Heavy, frag mich nicht, seh ich jetzt von hier, ah
doch, vielleicht auf der Fernbedienung, ne, bevor sie fortfahren, ja was ist denn Google,
naja, ich stimme allem zu, Mitsubishi Heavy Splitgeräte, da hab ich was von, wenn es euch
interessiert, kann ich genau nachgucken, aber ich glaub, so wirklich interessant ist es
eigentlich nicht, grad Sommerurlaub für ein paar Jahre, die Leute von DHL kriegen es nicht
gebacken, der ist in Zustellung Flo96, der ist in Zustellung der Raspberry, allerdings
hab ich so meine Zweifel, dass der heute ankommt, Brexit nie wieder Pi kaufen, der kann es ja
in Deutschland, der soll halt andere importieren, oh meine Shift-Taste wackelt übelst, was
denn da los, Moment, was, so ein Dreck, kann es eigentlich nicht fliegen, also ich mein,
die Tastatur ist eigentlich für den Preis übelst der Mist, aber richtig Mist, wenn
ich überlege, wie teuer dieses Corsair Ding war, außer RGB kann sie nix, die Tasten haben
doppelte Anschläge teilweise, wenn jetzt auch noch die Shift-Taste anfängt zu, ah
ne, Windows, Windows nicht nerven, die Shift-Taste anfängt zu wackeln, und zwar richtig anzuwackeln,
so als hält sie nicht richtig, was denn da los, was ist das, ne, Leute, das ist das Geld
nicht wert, die Tastatur, die wackelt so als hält, als hält die Taste, achso, ja kein
Wunder, die Feder auf der rechten Seite ist kaputt von der Taste, kommt mir zumindest
so vor, Crap, richtiger Crap, Huge Massive Crap, hast du ihn jetzt doch schon, nein er
ist noch auf Inzustellung, deswegen, also ich hab mir ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht,
was wir heute machen könnten, wenn der Raspberry Pi nicht kommt, und ich geh mal davon aus,
dass er nicht mehr auftaucht, also es gibt ein paar Sachen, eins davon, also ich erzähl
euch einfach mal, was wir machen könnten, ja, im Endeffekt, ähm, wir könnten, wir könnten
ein bisschen ausprobieren, ach ne, Moment, ich zeig euch, bevor wir uns überlegen, was
wir heute machen, ich zeig euch mal den Scam des Jahres, das wollt ich euch eh noch zeigen,
ich hab heute, äh, nicht der Scam des Jahres, das ist ein bisschen zu viel, ja, der Scam
des Jahrzehnts, ich hab heute einen Screenshot von gepostet, genau, diese Werbung hab ich
heute Morgen gekriegt, ja, das hab ich, der Eichler, das hab ich mir aufgeschrieben,
das wollt ich auch grad vorschlagen, eins davon, also Morgen hab ich die Werbung gekriegt,
Hilfe gegen langsames WLAN, weil das Bild ist schonmal genial, ne, Kabel reinstecken
gegen langsames WLAN, ja, das macht das WLAN mit Sicherheit deutlich besser, wenn man Kabel
reinsteckt, ähm, und dann, winziges Gerät verdoppelt die Internetgeschwindigkeit und
verstärkt WLAN-Signal um 300%, so, normalerweise mach ich sowas ja zu, weil ich mir denke,
ja, Scam für'n Arsch, aber ich hab dann mal draufgeklickt und ich hab's mir irgendwo
in die Bookmarks gemacht, die Seite müssen wir uns jetzt mal zusammen angucken, weil
das ist schon wieder so dumm, dass es, dass es echt lustig ist, also, das Ding, was man,
was, was, was diese Sachen hier bewirbt, nennt sich, jetzt kommt schonmal, jetzt kommt schonmal
der Name SuperboosterWi-Fi, wenn schonmal SuperboosterWi-Fi heißt, so, und wie krieg ich denn jetzt die
Uhr am besten vom iPhone auf den, ich, ich such mal, ich such mal danach, New Incognito
wieder, ich will nicht, dass die mir irgendwie, ach so, wie kann man eigentlich, oh, weißt
das hier, man musste doch irgendwie seine Addons, seine Addons white-listen, dass die
im Incognito-Modus funktionieren, ähm, wie, oh, wie ging das nochmal?
Nee, Haken setzen Details, was, wo Details, ich seh's nicht, ah, ach hier, allow incognito,
ah, ok, sehr schön, da können wir jetzt noch das neue Incognito-Tab aufmachen, ich will
nicht, dass die mich tracken, genau, so, und die Uhr war, also eben das Ding hieß SuperboosterWi-Fi,
also das da, best HD-Antenne, Erfahrungszentrale, Moment, Moment, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss
die original, die original Werbung aus dem Scam raussuchen, weil die ist schon wirklich,
hier, da, ich hab mir die Uhr aufgeschrieben, ähm, the gadget review guy, klingt schon,
klingt schon sehr, sehr vertrauenserweckend, ja, ähm, d-e-pre, der Name allein schon, ja,
.html, ja, ja, also, das ist die Story hinter dem, hinter der Werbung, also, ich hab mir
das vor Augen, wir lesen uns das jetzt nicht komplett, wir gucken, wir lesen uns das nicht
komplett durch, ähm, nur mal so, nur mal so die Highlights, also, wenn man auf diese Anzeige
klickt, kommt man halt, kommt man halt letztendlich hier raus, so, und was die halt hier bewerben
ist schon mal irgendwie ganz lustig, als erstes sieht man hier ein komisches DSL-Modem oder
was das sein soll, und das eigentliche Gerät, ja, dann ist der Fake-Techniker angeblich
da, der, der dann da irgendwas macht, und, und dann kriegt, dann kriegt er am Ende dieses
Gerät, und das macht die Welt dann wieder viel besser, und, ihr müsst euch nur mal das
Intro durchlesen, es reicht schon, es, es, das ist Megaskamars, ey, es reicht schon,
wenn man das hier liest, dieses bahnbrechende Gerät macht lahmes WLAN wieder flott und
enthüllt, jetzt kommt's, wie sie von gierigen Internetprovinern abgezockt werden, das ist,
ähm, noch schlimmer als, als die ganzen Clickbait-Anzeigen, ähm, so diese Clickbait-Anzeigen
so nach dem Motto, ähm, Hausfrau erfindet wahnsinniges Rezept, äh, gegen, äh, zum
abnehmen, Mediziner hassen sie dafür, so, und das ist noch mal ne Nummer schlimmer,
das ist noch mal ne Nummer schlimmer, also, die Story, obwohl, was da, die labern hier
im Endeffekt rum, das ist dann irgendwie der arme Rico, der ist 52 Jahre alt, und kann
endlich von zu Hause arbeiten, und das funktioniert auch, also würde theoretisch funktionieren,
das funktioniert nicht, weil er von seinem Internetprovider beschissen wird, denn, der
Internetprovider macht es langsamer, als wofür er bezahlt, ja, oh, das heißt, der
Internetprovider ist schon mal ganz böse, das zumindest ist so die Fazit, so, der,
der ersten, ersten Abschnitt, so, von diesem Artikel, und dann kommt der, ähm, und dann
kommt die Erklärung, wie er jetzt auf den tollen, äh, Wifi-Repeater, da steht übrigens mal
von Booster, das ist ein ganz publischer Repeater wieder, er gekommen ist, und zwar, ähm, es
kam dann irgendwann mal ein Techniker, weil, genau, ein Techniker ist vorbeigekommen, weil
er sich immer wieder beschwert hat beim Provider, wie langsam doch sein Internet ist, und bezahlt
er da so viel für, und das kann ja nicht sein, die haben das extra so geschrieben, dass sich
ganz viele Leute, vor allem viele Noobs, damit identifizieren können, ja, so, und dann kommt
der Techniker, und das ist ergeblich der Techniker, ja, natürlich, legit, seems legit, eindeutig,
ja, weil wer, wer kennt nicht den, den Techniker, der da so ausschaut, der dann an irgendeinem,
äh, Netgear, TP-Link, äh, Stealth-Bomber-Router rumfrickelt, was auch, was auch immer der
Techniker da macht, ein blaues Kabel reinstecken, kein Wunder, dass sein Internet nicht funktioniert
hat, ja, und die absoluten Profi-Handschuhe, absoluten Profi-Handschuhe, das ist, das ist
eher der Techniker, der dir dann auf die Fresse haut, wenn es nicht funktioniert, und diese
komische Schutzbrille, oder was das ist, naja, es ist halt, es ist halt ordentlich Scam-Mast,
ja, so, und zumindest, der Techniker ist dann fertig, ihr müsst dann den Mist nicht durchlesen,
der Techniker ist dann irgendwann fertig, und, ähm, der Techniker und hier unser, unser
Typ hier da, der mit dem, der, der, der Hipster-Typ mit dem, mit dem MacBook, das sieht, wobei
der Typ sieht gar nicht so hipster aus, das ist wahrscheinlich das Gamars-Typ, oder wahrscheinlich
ein Stock-Foto, ähm, hat sich, hat sich so gut mit dem Techniker verstanden, und die
haben dann, die haben dann miteinander, miteinander gesprochen, und dann hat ihm der Techniker
quasi die Wahrheit offenbart, dass er in ein paar Wochen die gleichen Probleme wiederkriegt,
die er vorher auch bekommen hat, und, ähm, daraufhin war natürlich, äh, wie hieß er,
Rico empört, hat gesagt, wie kann das denn sein, ich bezahle da doch Geld für, und daraufhin
hat ihm der Techniker das Geheimnis verraten, es ist nämlich so, dass, ähm, die Internet
Anbieter in Wirklichkeit, alle, deswegen lohnt sich auch ein Anbieterwechsel nicht, es lohnt
sich nur den Wi-Fi Booster Plus zu kaufen, ähm, es ist leider schon das wieder beknackt
ist, und, ähm, die Wahrheit ist nämlich, laut diesem Beitrag da, dass die Internet
Anbieter in Wirklichkeit immer zwei Leitungen liegen, falls sie das noch nicht, falls sie
das noch nicht wusstet, also, die Anbieter legen immer zwei Leitungen, eine Leitung,
wenn sie, ähm, quasi beschuldigt werden, das Internet ist nicht schnell genug, dann
nehmen sie diese Leitung, um zu beweisen, dass, ist das dämlich, ähm, um zu beweisen,
dass die Leitung schnell genug ist, wenn du allerdings surfst, dann benutzen die Anbieter
die langsame Leitung, wo du getrosselt wirst, ja, so, so ist das, so, und dann hat der Hersteller,
äh, nicht der Hersteller, der Techniker, weil er sich so gut mit Rico verstanden hat, hat
der, hat der, hat der Techniker gesagt, Rico mein Freund, ähm, sag, sag, gib mein Handy,
alter, und hat dann, hat gesagt, Rico, ich geb dir was, was alle deine Probleme löst,
und dann ist der Techniker zum Auto gegangen, und hat Rico quasi das beste Gerät aller
Zeiten geholt, nämlich den Super, ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie er heißt, den
Super Booster Wi-Fi Plus, der irgendwie hier nur noch aussieht wie ein stinknormaler WLAN
Repeater, aber laut diesem Artikel ist das grandios, ja, und, und dann sagt natürlich
der Techniker noch dabei, sie haben das nicht von mir bekommen, okay, dieses Teil nennt
sich Super Booster Wi-Fi, gucken wir mal, wir gucken da mal gleich, wir gucken uns mal
die Scammer Seite an, wir müssen, wir müssen uns das gleich noch ein bisschen genauer angucken,
ja, neugierig auf diesen Super Booster Wi-Fi haben wir uns dazu entschlossen, selbst ein
paar Recherchen durchzuführen, oh ja, diese wahnsinnig, äh, quasi weltbekannte, äh,
wie, Netzwerk-Equipment-Testing-Seite, The Gatchan Review Guy, hat sich dazu entschieden,
das zu testen, ja, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, was da rauskommt, da würde es tatsächlich
auch funktionieren, wir entschieden uns das einmal auszubringen, aktualisieren, der war
im Fernsehen zu sehen, ernsthaft, und dann diese geilen Fake, Alter, diese Fake-Facebook-Dinger,
sind das überhaupt echte, das ist kein echtes Facebook, oder, das ist Fake-Facebook, guckt
mal, das ist Scammers, und schon richtig schlechter Scammers, du bist in Kokkito, genau, deswegen
kann ich ja wohl auch kaum Facebook liken, das ist, das ist Fake-Scammers, ja, aber ich
mein, ey, wenn Janina Spielmann mit irgendeinem geklauten Foto von der Universität Freiburg,
die Oma auf dem Bild sieht auch genauso aus, wie eine aus der Universität Freiburg, ist
perfekt, bestes Produkt, ganz toll, so, gucken wir uns das Produkt mal an, was macht das
denn tolles, verzichten sie in die Videos auf schnelles Video, irgendwie reden die schon,
ja, ja, ist klar, vor 39 Minuten haben sie das gekauft, natürlich, reloaden wir mal die
Seite, ob der gleiche wieder vor 39 Minuten gekauft hat, oder ob die wenigsten so clever
waren, und das Ganze randomized haben, irgendwie, genau, man kann das Gerät direkt auf der
Review-Seite kaufen, oh nein, es ist randomized, wer den Kram kauft, über uns, ok, das müssen
wir uns auch mal angucken, wer dahinter steckt, bestellen sie noch heute, halten sie 50% Rabatt,
jetzt ist es übrigens hier von 300%, und die kaufen ja wie verrückt, vielleicht ja auch
real, ganz bestimmt, was real an dem Gerät sein wird, wahrscheinlich, dass es ein WLAN-Repeater
ist, so, und, also, da geht ja ab, aus Mainz der nächste, garantiert, beste Qualität,
übrigens, ist hier jetzt von 300% schneller, gar nicht mehr die Rede, sondern nur noch
von 300 Megabit, also, so, ganz, ist das irgendwie, das sagen unsere Kunden, alles top Bewertungen,
sogar Michelle, Alter, Michelle, bist du auch hier, aus Frankfurt am Main, jetzt kaufen
und sparen, wollen wir mal gucken, was der Kram kostet, bestellen wir, naja, also, sag
man mal so, für einen WLAN-Repeater, das ist jetzt im Rahmen, und, im Endeffekt, ist das
ja auch unter der Haube, ziemlich sicher, ein stinknormaler WLAN-Repeater, ne, ist das
hier, guck mal, das ist noch schlechteres Facebook, das ist noch schlechteres Facebook,
als vorher haben sie ja zumindest noch den Click gefaked, und, jetzt haben sie, jetzt
geht gar nichts mehr an den Facebook-Bewertungen, die verfügbare, ey, das ist, das ist Scamas,
die billigsten Scamas-Taktiken überhaupt, ja, so nach dem Motto, Fake Reviews, Fake Bestellungen,
Fake Knappheit, Fake Rabatt, das ist, ja, die bestellen ja wie verrückt, ja, das geht
hier ab, die verfügbare Menge ist leider sehr begrenzt, und der Rabatt von 50 auf das Review
könnte jederzeit vorbei sein, oh nein, was machen wir da bloß, Vornamen, Nachnamen,
na, dann machen wir jetzt nichts, 30-Tage-Garantie, also, das ist ja sowas, ne, das reizt mich
dann manchmal, das einfach mal auszuprobieren, und dazu sagen, ich bin damit nicht zufrieden,
kann man denen eine Nachricht schreiben, brauchen sie Hilfe, oh, ich muss mir beim Sebaro unbedingt
eine anonyme E-Mail machen, dann schreiben wir denen mal, das muss ich mir boocken, als
nächstes, nächsten Stream, Leute, schreiben wir den Superbooster, mal irgendeine dumme
E-Mail, ach ja, übrigens, China, wo wir gerade dabei sind, es ist, es ist China, es ist
China, WLAN-Repeater, wir schreiben den, nächsten Stream, ich mach beim Sebaro die, die Wubblos-Wegwerf-Adressen-Namama, nächsten Stream schreiben wir mal dem Superbooster eine E-Mail, und fragen
die ein paar Sachen, zum Beispiel, ob VLANs unterstützt werden, oder, keine Ahnung, ob
man sich per SSH einloggen kann, das ist irgendwie ein bisschen Blödsinn, wo die wahrscheinlich
sagen, Alter, was will der Typ von uns, ja, dann würde ich gerne wissen, ob es den Superbooster,
weil ich meine, der Superbooster beschleunigt ja mein ganzes Netzwerk, ob es den Superbooster
auch in 10 Gigabit Ausführung gibt, wann ist der nächste Stream, zwei Monaten, so, ich
stream doch aktuell fast täglich, ja, dann machen wir den Skamars-Scheiß mal zu, sonst,
kauft sich das noch irgendjemand, ja, Raspberry ist übrigens immer noch nicht da, so, hast
du gesehen, dass die Raspberry-Org-Seite jetzt mit einem Cluster von 18 Raspberries läuft,
172 Kerne, 72 G-RAM, unter 100 Watt Stromverbau, ne, hab ich nicht gesehen, aber mit dem neuesten
Update eignen sich die Raspberries, finde ich, mittlerweile ziemlich gut dafür, also das
letzte Update hat halt nochmal Out of Order Execution und vor allem ein bisschen mehr
CPU-Leistung draufgepackt, eignen sich die richtig gut dafür, so ein paar kleine Cluster
zu bauen, für zwei Anwendungsbereiche, denke ich, einmal, um ein bisschen zu üben, ja,
zum Beispiel, hat mal auf der Arbeit einer erzählt, der überlegt, ob er sich nicht
so einen Test-MongoDB-Cluster hinbaut, mit ein paar Raspberries, einfach zum Üben, und
ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn man tatsächlich, was hat, was man richtig gut parallelisieren
kann, dann lohnt sich das auch, ein paar Raspberries daheim hinzustellen, also, rein von Leistung
zu Stromverbrauch her, ne, geschwindigkeitsmäßig wirst du damit im Vergleich zu einem ordentlichen
Radwerk keinen Blumentopf gewinnen, aber Stromverbrauch zur Leistung sind die, glaube ich,
ganz gut.
Max, teilen Sie bitte die Scam-Seite im Chat, ne, du kannst einfach weiter zurückscrollen
im Stream, wo ich es eingebe, oder nachgucken im Stream, ich will die nicht in Chat posten,
sonst kaufen sich das noch Leute, oder Twitch sagt der Max spams gar maßlings, ja, also
unabhängig davon, ob der Raspberry noch kommt oder nicht, wir müssen ja heute irgendwas
machen, hast du dir schon das neue Windows Terminal angeguckt, ja, hab ich, hab ich,
und zwar, wir haben uns das hier zusammen angeschaut, im Stream, haben wir uns das zusammen
angeschaut, nämlich, in eine extra Windows VM, die wir dafür gemacht haben, und zwar
in der hier, wo ich einstachte, ach Moment, das ist die falsche VM, das ist die falsche
VM, das ist die richtige VM, ja, und ich hab auch, ich hab auch direkt Bugs gefunden
im Terminal, aber das haben wir uns hier zusammen angeguckt, also ich hab als, während die
Windows VM booted und ich das mal hier dem Skylar nochmal kurz zeige, was wir uns angeschaut
haben, also, als Vorschlag, was wir heute machen können, bis der Raspberry kommt, beziehungsweise,
wo wir einfach mit anfangen, wie gesagt, ob der Raspberry kommt, ist fraglich, um 18.50
noch, hast du dem neuen Terminal nicht vertraut, warum eine VM, weil ich es nicht installieren
konnte unter meinem normalen Windows, weil der Windows Showroom, Windows Store rumgespackt
hat, eben konnte ich ja 111 eingeben und es kam das Terminal, jetzt kommt nicht mehr
das Terminal, aber da ist es, ja, also, unser Fazit, mehr oder weniger einstimmig, das letzte
Mal, fast einstimmig, war eigentlich, Microsoft ist auf einem ganz guten Weg mit der neuen
Konsole, man kann mittlerweile, oh fuck, mach mal den Scheiß aus, weg, das war nochmal
Emoji Punkt, genau, man kann mittlerweile Emojis einfügen und auch ordentlich Emojis
copypasten, funktioniert alles, wichtigste Feature ever, Farbcodes und Escape-Sequenzen
werden ordentlich unterstützt, das einzige Problem ist, dass der manchmal noch ein bisschen
Hotkeys verschluckt und man zum Beispiel aus dem Wim, ach jetzt gehts, letztes Mal sind
wir aus dem Wim gar nicht mehr rausgekommen, egal mit welcher, wofür man Emojis in der
Konsole braucht, als Gitprom, das ist das wichtigste, das Allerwichtigste ist das, in
der Konsole, also ich könnte, ich könnte meine Konsole nicht mehr ohne Emojis verwenden,
aus dem Wim kann man nicht raus, also wir fallen, wir fallen, wir fallen ein, lass mal
überlegen, Doppelpunkt Q kannst du machen, Doppelpunkt WQ, blablabla, Doppelpunkt Q
ausrufen, alles im Prinzip das gleiche, du kannst machen Doppelpunkt X und meine persönliche
Lieblingskombination, um aus Wim rauszugehen ist Shift ZZ, weil selbst wenn das irgendwelche
Sachen und Zeichen verschluckt, Shift ZZ oder Y, Y, je nach Dings, je nach Layout, geht
eigentlich immer, allerdings selbst das hat letztes Mal nicht funktioniert und im Zweifel
machen wir einfach die Konsole zu, also Microsoft ist finde ich mit ihrem neuen Terminal wirklich
auf einem guten Weg, das Ding braucht natürlich noch ein bisschen Performance und ob die Integration
von Windows und, und, und Linux Subsystem, ne Windows Subsystem von Linux jemals wirklich
gut ist, mal abwarten, aber sie sind auf jeden Fall auf dem, auf dem richtigen Weg dafür.
So, was ich mir überlegt hab, was wir heute machen können, bis der Raspberry kommt oder
falls der Raspberry nicht kommt, fangen wir jetzt damit schon mal an, also ich hätte,
ich hätte zwei Sachen, zwei Sachen zur Auswahl, hast du eine Idee, warum zählen der auf keinem
Mal kein Scoop mehr findet beziehungsweise auswürft, ähm, sag ich dir gleich, ob das
bei mir auch so ist, ähm, also ich hätte zwei Sachen zur Auswahl, was wir machen könnten,
wir könnten einmal, dass, sag mal, hängste irgendwie, ah jetzt, äh, wir könnten einmal,
dass, ähm, Chat, Chat, ähm, Adwoblos Fragen, ähm, Q, Tool anfangen zu programmieren, also
nur mal so zu erklären, was das letzte Mal einer vorgeschlagen, dass, ähm, weil ich
mit dem Chat und Fragen überhaupt nicht nachgekommen bin, dass man doch ein Tool programmieren
könnte, was quasi im Chat, quasi im Hintergrund mitliest, im Twitch-Chat und alle Sachen,
die Adwoblos enthalten und eine gewisse Länge haben, vielleicht auch ein Fragezeichen enthalten
oder was auch immer, dass die dann automatisch gescannt werden und quasi in, in, in so eine
Art To-Do-Liste reinkommen, dass ich nachgucken kann, was es für Fragen gab, die ich noch
nicht beantwortet habe. Das hat letztes, letztes Mal einer als Idee gebracht, das fand ich
eigentlich eine super Geschichte. Ich konnte mir vorstellen, dass die üblichen Sachen,
so, dass irgendwie vielleicht ein Nightboard oder Tippy Stream oder Streamlabs oder so,
dass sie das können, aber sowas selbst programmieren wäre, denke ich, mal ganz cool. So, also,
zumindest mal anfangen heute damit. Das ist eine Sache zur Auswahl und die zweite Sache
zur Auswahl ist, wir können ja, wir können ja mal in Strawpool machen, was wir machen
wollen. Nicht Pool, Poll. FakeSite ist auch ScamBars hier,.de. Und die zweite Option,
die zweite Option ist, wir können die, haben wir von ein paar Streams, haben wir ja den,
den ESP32 Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor, den ESP32 programmiert und ich würde gerne mal ein
bisschen experimentieren mit Multithreading auf dem ESP32. Also, das wäre dann wieder
der Low-Level-Geschichte. Weil das Ding hat zwei Kerne und einen Low-Power-Kern, also
da kann man auf jeden Fall Multithreading betreiben und mal ausprobieren, was man damit
alles machen kann und dann versuchen quasi Multithreaded mal Sachen über LoRa zu übertragen,
sprich ein Thread liest Sensordaten, ein anderer Thread baut Verbindung auf und schickt. So,
die zwei Sachen haben wir zur Auswahl. Also, Option 1, Chat-Tool, Chat-Tool programmieren,
das wird, ja, ach ja, haha, wir machen danach noch eine zweite Umfrage. Chat-Tool programmieren
oder ESP32 Multithreading plus LoRa. Ok, Create Poll. Kann ich euch das jetzt überhaupt
zeigen, wenn ich das hier im Stream aufmache? Sieht man dann irgendwas, was mich skirmast?
Title is required. Ok, also, könnt euch daran auslassen. Ach ja, die dritte Option, die
ich jetzt nicht draufgeschrieben habe, wo wir auch nicht für abstimmen müssen, wenn
der Raspberry Pi 4 kommt, fangen wir damit an. Ok, Chat-Tool programmieren, LoRa. Also,
ich sehe, die Low-Level-Fraktion ist nicht so sehr vertreten wie die High-Level-Fraktion,
was genau ist LoRa? LoRa ist ein Long-Range-Funk-Übertragungsprotokoll. Aber es wand liefert DHL, ich glaube,
potenziell bis 21 Uhr. Ok, also, so wie ich das feststelle, jetzt mal so von den paar
Votes, die eingegangen sind, die überwiegende Teil möchte Chat-Tool haben. Das andere machen
wir aber auch auf jeden Fall. Wenn du Low-Level willst, musst du abstimmen. Das andere machen
wir aber auch auf jeden Fall, weil ich mein, wenn ich jetzt schonmal im Streaming-Flow quasi
bin, dann, na, da brauchen wir ja auch Content für die nächsten paar Streams. Ok, Chat-Tool
programmieren. Dann hätte ich noch eine weitere Frage an euch. Wenn wir Chat-Tool programmieren,
dann ist die Frage, wie gesagt, wir machen es auf jeden Fall, wir machen es auf jeden
Fall in C-Sharp. Und jetzt ist die Preisfrage. Bisher haben wir das immer unter Windows
gemacht. Wir haben das immer gemacht unter Windows mit Visual Studio. Also wir machen
es auf jeden Fall in.NET Core Chat-Tool. So, und das ist die Frage, wollen wir das
wieder unter Windows mit Visual Studio machen oder wollen wir mal zur Abwechslung das Ganze
unter Linux mit Rider machen? Ich glaube, wir haben.NET Entwicklung noch nie unter
Linux gemacht hier im Stream. So. Oh, das ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen knapper.
Oh, Windows kackt ab. Linux plus Wim. Vergiss es. Vergiss es. Ich mach hier, ich mach hier
kein, ich mach gar hier kein.NET Unter mit in Wim. Da bist du so auf ordentliche Autoverfond-Ständigung
und Hilfen, die dir anzeigen, nicht wirklich angewiesen, aber machts viel angenehmer und
das ist im Wim grausam. Äh, was für ein Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor benutzt du? Resistiv oder Kapazitiv? Äh, Kapazitiv.
Und zwar den da. Nein, nicht für diese komische Handyhülle. Immer mach ich, nee das war
anders. Immer mach ich diese komische Handyhülle auf. Wim oder Unsup? Ich kann dir meine Wim-Hazel
zeigen. Das ist das einzige, was ich dir heute Wim technisch bieten kann. Ähm. Den da hab
ich. Das ist nämlich das Gute an dieser Sorte von Sensoren, die rosten halt nicht oder ich
weiß nicht ob rosten das richtige Wort ist. Die gehen aber nicht kaputt. Die anderen,
die Billishina Sensoren, die messen irgendwie quasi zwischen zwei Beinchen quasi irgendwie
den Widerstand zwischen so zwei Beinchen und die eine Seite fängt dann an sich abzulösen.
Das ist schlecht. Was dieser Sensor hier nicht tut. So, mal gucken was rausgekommen ist. Wow!
Da hat's aber nochmal umgehauen jetzt eher. Jetzt hat er tatsächlich Windows vorne auf
einmal. Das war ja, ich hab jetzt schon gedacht, ich muss weiter installieren, aber es war
der G-Bait. Aber es ist schon ziemlich 50-50. Ja, dann würde ich sagen, da bleibt uns nichts
anderes übrig, wenn das so 50, das ist ja wirklich nahezu 50-50, 32-34. Ähm, dann würde
ich sagen, machen wir das so, wir sind mal ganz wagemutig, wir machen das auf Windows
und Linux. Also sprich, wir probieren mal ein kleines Beispiel zu basteln, so einen kleinen,
kleinen Test, wie man das machen könnte, unter Windows und unter Linux. Und wir fangen
mal unter Windows an, weil das gewonnen hat, machen das Ganze dann aber auch unter Linux.
Im Prinzip ändert sich der Code ja nicht großartig, aber ich wollte schon immer mal Rider unter
Linux ausprobieren. Und wir fangen jetzt mal unter Windows an. Also, was ich gelesen
hab, wie man das machen kann am besten für den Twitch-Chat ist, dass der Twitch-Chat
unter der Haube IRC ist. Ja, also unter der Haube ist der Twitch-Chat IRC und man kann
sich mit, man kann sich nen randomen Name generieren und kann sich anonym connecten.
Das bedeutet, wir müssen uns kein AP-Key generieren oder einen neuen Fake-Account anlegen
oder sonst was. Wir können Read-Only auf den Chat zugreifen. Und Read-Only ist ja auch
das einzige, was wir brauchen. So, jetzt ist natürlich noch die Sache, wo wir uns überlegen
müssen, ist, verwenden wir irgendeine IRC-Library. Ich weiß gar nicht, was es da gibt, ehrlich
gesagt. Oder versuchen wir mal so die Basics selbst zu machen. Und nachdem ich noch nie
was mit IRC gemacht hab, würde ich eigentlich vorschlagen, wir suchen uns mal ein kleines
Beispiel raus und basteln das von Hand. Twitch kotzt aber richtig an. Die krempeln fast
jedes Jahr die komplette API um. Ja, wir verwenden ja auch nicht die Twitch-AP, wir connecten
uns zum Twitch-IRC-Server. Und IRC wird sich ja so schnell wahrscheinlich nicht ändern.
Und den Post, den ich gefunden habe, wie man sich anonym zum Twitch-Chat per IRC connecten
kann, ist von 2015. Und der funktioniert angeblich in 2019 immer noch. Also so schnell scheint
sich das nicht zu ändern. So, also die IRC-Libraries hätten wir, oder aber wir suchen mal nach
einem Beispiel. Wir suchen mal nach einem Beispiel. Very Minimal IRC-Client for Twitch. Das klingt
auch schon mal gut. Na, der ist wirklich minimal. Gut, das ist jetzt peisen, aber das in.NET
zu übersetzen, was der da macht, dürfte nicht allzu schwer sein. Ich würde sagen, dann
probieren wir doch mal aus, ob das funktioniert, ob man so den Twitch-Chat, ob man so sich zum
Twitch-Chat connecten kann. Das werden wir jetzt mal ausprobieren. Meistens Mockers.
Äh, ich ändere nochmal den Stream-Titel. Jemand einen guten Vorschlag für den Stream-Titel?
Ähm. Bearbeiten. Raspberry verschollen. Ähm. Ach komm, ich lasse den Stream-Titel einfach,
ist doch egal. Zweiter Stream in Folge. Das ist sogar der fünfte Stream oder so in Folge,
oder Leute? Ich habe in den letzten paar Tagen erstaunlich oft gestrebt. Okay, WhistleStudio
19. Ich hoffe, man kann beide parallel laufen lassen, weil ich habe hier noch mein... Ihhh.
Ist das jetzt euer Ernst? Jajajaja, baited. Ähm. Streamst du schon wieder, ja? Ja, ich
bin schon wieder hier. Okay, mit welchem Account bin ich denn hier eingeloggt? Ich mache
euch mal kurz aus. Sieht man doch überhaupt, in was er da eingeloggt? Ja. In 17 bin ich
überhaupt nicht eingeloggt. Okay, ähm. Ich bin in 17 gar nicht eingeloggt, ne? Aber warum
kann ich 17 denn dann verwenden? Aber ich war in 17 auf jeden Fall eingeloggt. Hm. Okay,
ich guck mal kurz. Ich hab mir hier irgendeinen Fake-Account gemacht. Ich muss mal kurz auf
den zweiten Bildschirm schauen. Was, was da so gibt. GitHub. GMX. Ah, super. Warum muss
man sich für jeden Scheiß eigentlich mittlerweile einloggen, ne? Keine Ahnung, was für ein Chaos.
Okay, ähm. Fuck geht mir das auf den Sack, äh. Na gut, dann müssen wir jetzt im Visual
Studio 17 machen. Auf, das nervt mich jetzt aber. Doch, Linux. Ja, eigentlich ist es die
beste Variante. Dann machen wir es mal unter Rider. Geht mir echt auf den Keks, ey. Was
soll denn der Mist? Vor allem, wo ist mein Account hin? Ah, hab ich jetzt, hab ich jetzt
ausgetrickst? Weil ich einfach zu schnell geklickt hab? Fuck. Geht nicht. Das ärgert
mich jetzt irgendwie. Das ist doch Mist, ey. Outlook? War das was mit Outlook? Fuck. Keine
Ahnung, was das für ein Account war. Warum darf ich den Visual Studio 17 verwenden? Allerdings
das andere nicht. Obwohl ich hier nicht signed in bin. Und ich war hier mal definitiv signed
in. Nee, ich hab keine Ahnung. Okay, dann müssen wir, Leute, dann müssen wir das doch
im Unternehmungsanfang, das Ganze. Ähm. Weil, okay, Rider ist schonmal installiert,
gut. Updaten wir mal. Vielleicht hab ich sogar schonmal was gemacht. Rider, Projects, nee.
Ach, Login ist auf, ist bei 17 keine Pflicht und bei 19 schon, oder? Na, geil. Naja. Es
ist auch schon okay im Endeffekt, ja. Es ist schon okay. Ich hab jetzt ja leider keinen
Microsoft-Account am Start. Was ist das für Distribution? Das ist Manjaro mit i3-WM als
Windows-Manager. So, während der ganze Krams, jetzt hier guck ich, ob ich nicht doch mal
einen Fake-Account machen könnte. Create one. Okay, Create account. WTF-Account sucked. Ach
so. Add. Get new email address. Outlook. Beste. WTF-Account sucked. Beste email Adresse. Isn't
available? Ernsthaft? Warum? Okay. Twitch-Chat. 2k19. Outlook.com. Ah, okay. I would like
information tips. Okay, ein Passwort. Okay, man sieht es nicht. Ich kann mir jetzt irgendein
Passwort ausdenken und ihr seht es nicht. Das ist schon mal gut. Nein. Next. Next. Next.
Don't save. What? R, 5, X, 4, W, Captcha, Beste, D, N, R, N, 4, 6. Next. E. Ja, nee.
Dann, dann doch nicht. Muss man nicht bestätigen? Okay. Null. Nee, nee, klar musst du es bestätigen.
Send SMS-Code. Ja. Wie, das ist optional? Wo kann ich es denn über... Also kann ich
es einfach sagen Send und dann Next. Ja, okay. Okay. Deutsch. Deutsch. Deutsch. Wir faken
uns. 0151 ist Telekom. Alter. Nein. Nicht optional. Keine Chance. Geht nicht. Kein
Fak account möglich. Denied. Ja, okay. Beschreckt. Willst du mal probieren die Virtual Studio
Version mit meinem Key zu erklären? Wenn du denn, wenn du denn den Key über hast. Klar,
warum nicht? Aber da muss ich kurz den Screen ausmachen. Vielleicht den Key, den Key machen
kann. Hast du einen PN? Okay. Moment, kann man hier überhaupt, wie aktiviert man überhaupt
per Key? Geht das überhaupt? Das geht doch überhaupt nicht. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht,
wie ich den Key eingeben soll. Ich brauche wahrscheinlich einen Account, auf dem ich
dann den Key binde. Näh. Ist crap. Wir fangen, wir machen, fangen jetzt Unterlednungs an.
Wir fangen jetzt Unterlednungs an. Okay. Rider ist drauf. Rider. Alter, ich habe heute echt
Glück, äh. Muss ich mal kurz ausmachen. Ich werde jetzt nämlich mal was machen. Wahrscheinlich
den JetBrains Leuten nicht so gefällt. Vermute ich mal. Ähm. So. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Ich habe jetzt nichts gesehen. Ich habe jetzt nichts gesehen. Wir starten jetzt unsere Evaluierung
von Rider. Ich habe das Programm noch nie in dem Fall gesehen. Keine Ahnung, was das
eigentlich ist. Was, was hat er jetzt für einen Schmerz? Was hat er jetzt für einen
Schmerz? Okay, man muss drauf gelockt klicken. Alles gut. Okay. Damit habe ich tatsächlich
noch nicht, nicht, sehr wenig bis nichts gemacht. Console Application. Switch. Chat. Wir haben
das, das ist glaube ich das aktuellste, was es aktuell gibt. Ähm. Schauen wir mal. Okay,
wir können, wir können das Ganze mal ein bissl, bissl, bissl größer machen. Dann gehe
weg. Ich glaube, ich glaube, man erkennt es so ganz gut, oder? Von der Größe her. Ich
denke, das ist, das ist ganz, ganz zinnig. So, wie führt man aus? Wahrscheinlich F5.
Blablabla. Die Bug. Hello World. Ja, wunderbar funktioniert. Kann man das auch noch größer
machen? Bildausgabe. Nee. Benutzt das jemand und hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, wie man
dem Ding sagen kann, dass ich, dass ich eine Konsole starten will und das nicht in der,
in der eingebauten Konsole haben möchte? Nee, das geht nicht. Das muss doch funktionieren.
Use External Console. Ist noch sogar ein, sogar ein Häkchen dafür da. The fuck? Oh.
Achso. Ja gut, jetzt müssen wir noch einen. Äh, was macht der denn da? Ach, das ist,
das ist diese komische JetBrains, wir autovervollständigen alles Geschichte. Okay, die Konsole ist ein
bisschen, bisschen fail. So, vom, vom Farbschema ist so ein bisschen, bisschen wir. Aber ich
glaube wir können damit leben, oder? Ja, das liegt halt hier am Farbschema. Aber ist okay,
passt. Ist mir, ist mir nämlich viel lieber als diese komische, als diese komische Crap
Konsole hier unten. Da können wir den Kram nämlich runterschieben und wir haben Platz,
wo man was sieht. Und wenn man was starten will, Debugger an, Hello World, bla, Enter
und zu ist. Ja, das ist doch viel schöner so. So, und kann man dem jetzt noch irgendwie
sagen, was der starten soll für eine externe Konsole? Nee, der nimmt, der nimmt die Fall,
ne? Naja, okay. Wo hast du das geändert? Ich hab ein Häkchen in den, in den, in den
run-Settings gemacht. Gibt's nun eigentlich schon.NET Core mit GUI? Äh, GUI gibt's
nix offizielles Cross-Platform. Es gibt nur für, für.NET Core 3 gibt es Windows Forms
und WPF-Unterstützung. Hallo Twitch Chat. Könnt ihr das ordentlich lesen? Ich geb zu,
die Farbgebung ist ein bisschen, äh, die Farbgebung ist ein bisschen Mist. Äh, Moment.
Ach so, da ist der, der Font ist einfach nicht richtig eingestellt. Ja, so ist doch viel
schöner, oder? Passt doch. Wie, das merkt er sich nicht. Ich bestell das doch nicht jedes
Mal um. Welches Terminal, was so genau im Terminal ist das? Da muss ich wahrscheinlich
Profiles eben irgendwie sagen, dass ich mein Default Profile ändern will. Ging das denn
noch mal? Das war übelst versteckt, das weiß ich noch. Das find, das finde ich nie. Ah,
hier, doch. Set, Set as Default. Okay, dann sollte es jetzt eigentlich richtig aufgehen.
Hallo? Starten? Wie wär's mit, wie wär's mit starten? Ah ja, okay. Jetzt alles gut, wunderbar,
passt. Ich bin zufrieden. Okay, also, dann programmieren wir mal unseren, unseren Twitchchat
IRC-Gedöns. Wo haben wir hier unser, unser, unseren Beispielcode gehabt? Da, den kopieren
wir uns mal rüber, zack. Also, was müssen wir machen? Blabla, Host, IRC, TwitchTV. Okay.
IRC, TwitchTV, TwitchTV. Dann brauchen wir als nächstes Port, Channel, blabla. Den
kopier ich mir mal. So, dann brauchen wir noch, Port, wir machen erst mal mit der Logik
weiter. Das brauchen wir, den Nickname brauchen wir auf jeden Fall. Justin Fan Random Number
ist das, womit man sich anmelden muss. Ja. Channel, Channel brauchen wir auch noch. Channel
ist Wublords, also wie der Channel, wie mein Kanal heißt. So, und Nick, Nick ist dann
quasi, dass da hier, Justin Fan Random, Random Number, also Justin Fan. Random Number, aber
es muss wahrscheinlich 5-stellig sein, denke ich mal. Boah, das wird jetzt unique genug
sein. Twitchchat IRC, ja, der ganze Twitchchat ist unten drunter, IRC. Deswegen bin ich
auch auf die Idee gekommen, dass es eigentlich relativ einfach sein müsste, das, das Ganze
zu machen. So, dann brauchen wir einen TCP-Client. Kann das Ding, ich muss mal ein bisschen Rider
Features ausprobieren. Das fand ich nämlich eben schon richtig gut, dass das einem TCP,
und das ist tatsächlich eine Sache, die Visual Studio so nicht macht. Habt ihr, ich weiß
nicht, ob ihr es gerade gesehen habt. Der bietet mir hier Sachen wie TCP-Client, bietet
er mir an zum einbinden, ohne dass ich die Namespace im Using drin hab. Und wenn man
hinterdrückt, macht er das Using direkt rein. Yes, it's Arch Linux. It's Manjaro, but it's
Manjaro. Blah, brauchen wir nicht. Wir machen jetzt im Prinzip das, was der Typ hier auch
macht. Ähm, okay. Äh, Moment, hier können wir gleich unseren Host angeben und Thai-Buddhist-Kalender.
Ja, genau den wollte ich an der Stelle haben und nichts anderes. Den Thai-Buddhist-Kalender.
Voll 667, okay. Jetzt, äh, connectet sich das Ding in, ähm, und jetzt müssen wir das
hier machen, so wie es aussieht. Ich find's schön, dass sie die Visual Studio Shortcuts
übernommen haben. Okay, jetzt sind wir connected. Jetzt müssen wir sagen, Using Client Get
Stream. Dann wird's automatisch aufgeräumt. Ähm, einfach nur mal ausprobieren, wie das
Ganze funktioniert. Wo macht der denn den Kram doppelt? Komisch. 0w, 0w gibt's noch
nicht im Chat. Jetzt kommen sie wieder alle. Ja, 0englisch, alter. Ja, ja. So, und jetzt
müssen wir ihm sagen, Client Write. Nee, Quatsch, Stream. Stream, Write. Also im Prinzip,
was wir jetzt gemacht haben, okay, dieses Features mit den Klammern irritiert mich.
Das irritiert mich, weil ich bin's gewohnt, Klammer auf Klammer zuzumachen und dann macht
er irgendwie manchmal doppelt. Das irritiert mich irgendwie. Ähm, so, also was wir im Prinzip
gemacht haben, wir haben jetzt eine TCP-Verbindung zu irc.twitch.tv auf Port 667 und in diese
Verbindung können wir jetzt einfach Beiz rein schreiben. Wie kann man eigentlich per Shortcut
von System zu System wechseln? Ähm, das ist in Windows eingebaut. Du drückst, ähm,
du drückst Steuerung, Windows-Taste, linke, linker Pfeil oder rechter Pfeil und dann kannst
du hier über deine verschiedenen Desktops wechseln, die du so hast. Oder mit diesem
Ding. Okay, du musst einmal noch Steuerung Alt vorher drücken, dass du aus VMWare aus
dem Fokus rauskommst. Also ich drücke im Endeffekt Steuerung Alt und dann Steuerung Windows-Taste
Pfeil links. So, wenn ich wieder zurück will, das. Ich hab auf meinem Main-Profil hab ich
ein Maus-Makro dafür, was das macht. Aber das hier kann im Prinzip jeder machen. Also
das mach ich hier ohne Maus-Makro gerade. Okay, jetzt können wir hier Beiz reinschreiben.
So, was der hier macht ist, also die Python-Variante, was der uns hier sagen möchte ist, der nimmt
diesen internen Python-String. Ich glaube, Python ist intern UTF-16. Ich glaub, die haben
zwei Bytes pro Zeichen irgendwie intern. Dotnet übrigens auch. Also da ist nix mit UTF-8,
dafür ist das Zeug zu alt. Was das hier macht in Python ist, die nehmen diesen String und
encoden ihn als UTF-8. Und das muss ich jetzt auch machen. Zwar kannst du dann sagen, encoding.utf8
und dann sagst du get-bytes. So, und da schreibt man jetzt den. Ah, dieses Klammer-Feature
ist wirklich nervig. Und da schreibt man jetzt. Zumindest ungewohnt. Und da schreibt man jetzt
den String rein, den man an den Server senden will, also an IRC-Twitch-TV. Und wir wollen.
Guck mal, das ist schön, da zeigt dir sogar die Parameter hier nebendran an. Das finde
ich schon ganz schick. Also hat paar nette Features, sowas, was ich jetzt auf den ersten
Blick sehe. So, User braucht man dann plus Host. Brauchen wir nicht. Wir sind modern,
wir nutzen C-Sharp String-Interpolation. Wo ich immer nicht die Syntax merken kann.
So, oder? War doch einfach ein Dollar davor, glaube ich. Und dann. Nee, Moment. Einfach
nur so, das war Ruby. Einfach nur so. Ja, genau, genau. Nee, es ist einfach nur so,
das ist nicht so. Oder? War es so? Nee, ich glaube, ich glaube, man muss, C-Sharp ist
es einfach nur so. Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken. So, und jetzt müssen wir einfach
hinten dran den Leer-Zeichen machen und dann. So, Cache-Chature-Newline. Okay. So. Und
dann senden wir das andere auch noch zum Server. Da bleibt hier nur noch Nickname. Mein Nickname
ist das da. Der Zeichen Cache-Chature-Newline. Danach kommt noch Join. Channel. Channel ist
Wobblors. Cache-Chature-Newline. Was wird gemacht? Wir versuchen gerade den Twitch-Chat zu lesen,
weil mein Raspberry immer noch nicht da ist und laut Post in Zustellung. So. Wir versuchen
gerade uns per IRC an den Twitch-Chat zu connecten und dann den Twitch-Chat auszulesen. Also
wir gucken jetzt erstmal, ob das Ganze funktioniert. Ich vermute mal, wenn wir das hier an den
IRC-Server, ich hab wie gesagt mit IRC selbst ewig nichts mehr gemacht. Ich hab schon Jahre,
fast Jahrzehnte gefühlt, kann IRC klein mehr installiert und IRC Sachen programmiert
hab ich noch nie. Allerdings weiß ich, IRC ist komplett Plain Text und vom Prinzip her
eigentlich nicht so kompliziert. Okay. Das heißt wir gucken jetzt einfach mal, was der
Server uns als Antwort gibt. Was der Server uns als Antwort gibt auf unsere Join-Geschichte.
Kann es sein, dass ich das in der falschen Reihenfolge gemacht hab? User Nick Join. Nee,
User Nick Join. Passt. Seit wann benutzt du den Rider? Seitdem Visual Studio, also erstens
nachdem wir ne Umfrage gemacht haben und Windows mit Visual Studio und Rider unter Linus fast
50-50 Punkte gekriegt haben. Danach wollte ich Visual Studio starten und meine Account
ist nicht mehr gelingt und ich kanns nicht benutzen. Hab ich mir gedacht? Scheiß drauf.
Machen wirs mal mit Rider. Okay. Reads. Jetzt müssen wir da irgendwie ne Weilschleim
oder so. Was denn? Span Bites? Buffer? Buffer? Na, das können wir einfacher haben. Stream
Reader. Ich glaube so dürfte das deutlich einfacher sein. Stream Reader. Und dann den
Stream rein. Und jetzt geben wir mal aus Reader Read Line. To End können wir nicht machen,
weil das Stream ist ja nicht zu Ende. So, jetzt schauen wir mal was der Server antwortet.
Ob der Server überhaupt was antwortet. Das sieht für mich so aus als funktionierts.
JustInFan56723, welcome GLHF. GG Eats. Bitte, bitte using GLHF. Ehh, ich würd sagen das
geht oder? Ups, was? Oh, oh geh weg. Ich will das schließen. Also ich würd sagen das
funktioniert. So, wie macht er das jetzt mit dem? Er hat, hat eigentlich, das Ding irgendwelche
Events wenn irgendwas ankommt oder so. Ne, das ist richtig Oldschool Stream. Und ne Sache
die mir auch noch fehlt, aber wahrscheinlich hat das Rider, ich sehs bloß nicht, dass
man filtern kann nach Events, Methoden, Properties und so. Ob nicht. Ehh, wer sagt, hier hat
gerade einer geschrieben ich soll Reader verwenden mit Using. Darf ich auch so, darf ich das
auch so machen? Ist das auch, ist das auch genehm? Was macht es denn? Ja aktuell lockt
es sich im Twitch Chat ein und lockt es sich im Twitch Chat ein, das war's. Wer macht es
aktuell noch nicht? Welches SDK? Wie SDK? Sockets? Nein, TCP Client. SDK, fuck. Wir verwenden
doch keine, wir verwenden doch keine. Ach ne, du meinst die.NET Core Version 2.2. Ist
das. Ok, was macht denn der Dude hier? Das ist irgendwie das Buffer Zeug, was wir mit
unserem Stream Reader nicht brauchen. Private Message? Message? Ping? Wie lese ich jetzt
den Wubblers Chat aus? Hallo Hexe. Ja ne, wir machen das ganz raw, wir wollen ja auch
keine, keine API Key und sowas skandieren. Private Message? Ist das, wenn ich was geschickt
kriege? Wisst ihr was? Ich lese einfach mal und mal gucken, mal gucken, was jetzt passiert.
Wir lesen es einfach mal. Äh, äh, Moment. Wir machen einfach hier. Bam. Pass drauf.
Reader. Was macht, was macht das Tool? Reader, Read, Read, Read. Nein. Blockt das dann,
wenn es nichts, wenn nichts mehr kommt? Wisst du es eigentlich, ne? Ja, ja guckt da, Leute.
Aja ja. Da ist er, der Chat. Der Netlify hat was geschrieben, das hier, das Max hat was
geschrieben. Ja, das ist ja, das ist ja, also, da ohne Scheiß, Leute, das ist ja nur wirklich,
gleich fliegt er wegen dem IRC Timer, ne. Geh vorher raus. Bam. Okay, aber die Ping
Message müssen wir auf jeden Fall da noch handeln. Ich muss kurz die Klimaanlage ausmachen,
das ist echt zu kühl. Okay, jetzt können wir das nämlich auch schön machen. Jetzt
müssen wir ja prinzipiell, jetzt müssen wir mal prinzipiell wieder ein bisschen funktionieren.
Also zumindest das Einlog und der Rest scheint nicht so kompliziert zu sein. Ich mach mal
kurz ein bisschen kleiner, so. Kann man, kann man doch denke ich immer noch ganz gut lesen.
So kühl. Tja. Ja, das wurde mir echt gerade ein bisschen kühl. Und zwar, wir haben jetzt
hier 22 Grad drin gehabt. Ne, warte mal, ich muss mal kurz auf die Temperatur gucken.
24 Grad, das war mir jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen kühl, ja. Was ist mit Poggers passiert? Poggers
heißt jetzt Poggi. Ich hab nirgendwo was gefunden, warum Poggers jetzt Poggi heißt. Ich vermute
mal, das ist auch der einzige Hinweis, den ich gefunden hab, dass Poggers in manchen
Channels gesperrt war, weil zu lange Caps Buchstaben und Poggi ist quasi kürzere Variante,
auch irgendwie ganz griffig und so kurz, dass es nicht unter Twitch Chat Filter fällt. Okay,
wir machen mal ne klasse Twitch Chat. Ups, äh, Moment. Ne klasse. Da ist Twitch Chat.
So, jetzt überlegen wir uns mal, wie hätte ich es denn gerne. Ich hätte es gerne, dass
das Ding nen Event wirft, wenn ne neue Nachricht da ist. Das klingt doch eigentlich erstmal
ganz sinnig. Das Ding soll nen Event werfen, wenn ne neue Nachricht da ist. Eventuell sogar
schon ne neue Nachricht, wo, äh, Adwoblords drin steht. Und dann machen wir nen extra Thread
auf, der einfach ne Beinschleife hat und den Kram liest. Das klingt jetzt erstmal ganz
einfach. Okay, also was brauchen wir denn hier als Konstruktor? Äh, da brauchen wir
eigentlich, wenn wir ehrlich sind, höchstens den Channel. Höchstens den Channel, dass
man theoretisch den ganzen Kram in. Kann er das auch hier? Oh. Okay, dann machen wir
es mal so. Das ist, ähm, das ist der gängigere Style, die ne ganze Weile stand in den offiziellen
Microsoft Style Guides, dass man private, ähm, so Klassenvariablen nicht mit nem Unterstrich
macht, sondern einfach nur klein schreibt. Allerdings, Microsoft macht das selbst in
ganz vielen, an ganz vielen Stellen. Also, machen wir es mal so. Also, ist ja, ich mach
es normalerweise auch gerne ohne dieses, ohne den Unterstrich. Aber das Geschmackssache.
Ähm, es gibt einmal diesen Style hier mit dem Unterstrich und dann gibt es das, was
ich eigentlich ganz gerne mache, das ist, dass ich quasi ausschreibe. So mach ich das
normalerweise. Das ist Geschmackssache. Kann man machen, wie man will. M-Variable, stimmt,
hab ich auch schon gesehen. Oh, was meckert der hier jetzt eigentlich? Ah, okay, dass
das nicht benutzt wird. Sehr schön. Ja. Okay, gut, dann machen wir jetzt hier irgendwie
ne, kann man, kann man hier Void-Methode generieren oder sowas? Method? Äh, okay, brauch ich.
Ähm, Void, irgendwie Connect oder so. Oder Void, keine Ahnung. Run, Start. Wir machen
Start, das klingt so nach Task, irgendwie. Ähm, es ist, wisst ihr, dass das ziemlich
schwierig ist? Ähm, zwischen, zwischen Arduino, C, C++, Zeug und C Sharp, irgendwie von einem
Tag auf den anderen, um es wieder zu wechseln. Da denkste irgendwie falsch. So, Start. So,
wenn ich Start mache. Also, Channel, Brauma, Host. Host ist immer das gleiche. Host ist
immer das gleiche. Ähm, Nickname machen wir auch mal immer das gleiche. Können wir noch,
können wir noch random generieren jedes Mal? Äh, Channel haben wir hier. Boah, ansonsten,
ansonsten brauchen wir da eigentlich nix mehr. Sieht, sieht wie IntelliJ aus, ja, das liegt
daran, dass es vom gleichen, von den gleichen Typen ist. So. Okay, Start, Task gleich, Task,
Run. Oder wie war das, wie konnte man dem noch mal Long Running sagen? Ja. Task, Run,
geht so auch auf jeden Fall, da läuft er aber im Pool, glaube ich. Man konnte ihn noch irgendwo
sagen Long Running. Was war das mit New Task? Task Creation Options, genau. Ja, da konnte
man ihm irgendwie sagen Long Running. Das geht doch anders, oder? Naja, wir machen erst
mal ganz normal, Task, Run, ähm, mach das da eigentlich. So, und da drin können wir jetzt
unsere, was wird heute Abend gemacht? Naja, eigentlich wollten wir Raspberry, äh, den
Raspberry 4 etwas genauer unter die Lupe nehmen, allerdings ist er laut DHL immer noch in Zustellung.
Wurde JetBrains nicht von Google aufgekauft? Nicht, dass ich wüsste. So. Ah, diese Klammerung,
so das ist doch 0815, äh, so, Standardklammerung. Das Einzige, was mir bei den Default Settings
in Visual Studio auch nicht gefällt ist, dass die immer vier, vier Leerzeichen für, für
einen Block nehmen. Ich find's mit zwei eigentlich viel schöner, zumal das, äh, finde ich, die
Sache einfach erlesbar macht. So, Task, Run, da machen wir jetzt eigentlich unsere, boah,
eigentlich, wir können, wir können noch ne, wir machen was, wir machen was, wir machen
das anders. Wir machen hier Private, Private Void, äh, keine Ahnung, irgendwie Work oder
so, äh, und da machen wir den ganzen Mist drinne, dann können wir uns das nämlich sparen.
So, was hat das für Schmerzen? Fuck, Moment, warum geht das nicht?
Geht das nicht? Ja, äh, dass es über den Lambda geht, ist
klar, aber warum geht das so nicht? Wer ernsthaft, warum geht das nicht? Das ergibt da nicht
überhaupt keinen Sinn. Ich mein, klar, man kann, man kann, man kann den da machen und
dann den Kram aufrufen, aber, aber warum kann ich nicht direkt? Ich mein, das ist, das
ist quasi, äh, signaturmäßig, ich will da, äh, mit Hoden Aufruf haben ohne Argumente,
es wirkt doch auch. Ich, ich bilde mir ein, das hab ich auf einem der letzten, auf irgendeinem
der letzten Webcast gehört, dass das ne Sache ist, die, ich glaub mit C-Shop 8 oder so irgendwie
behoben ist, dass der besser, ähm, die Kandidaten auswählen kann, wenn's irgendwie mehrdeutig
ist, weil ich glaube, wenn wir das jetzt irgendwie casten oder so, dann funktioniert's nämlich.
Genau, so war das, dann funktioniert der Kram nämlich. Äh, wie kann man bilden? Einfach
so, ne? Ah, bla, bla, bla. Der Kram, was ist denn nur mit casten los, ne? Okay, da machen
wir jetzt unsere Weilschleife rein, die nix anderes macht, wie endlos vor sich hinzulupen.
Ah ne, connecten müssen wir uns ja vorher noch mal, Moment, das ist ja eigentlich Blödsinn.
Im Constructor, oder in Start können wir das eigentlich machen. In Start connecten wir
uns, haben wir nen TCP-Client, weil den brauch ich ja später noch, ähm. Ach ne, den kann
man jetzt hier gar nicht initialisieren. Doch, wenn ich den. Warum kam, warum ging das?
Nicht mehr, weil er. Ja gut, weil nicht klar ist, in welcher Reihenfolge der Kram initialisiert
wird, geh ich mal von aus. Was ist denn, wenn ich da reinschreibe, dass das ganze Const
sein soll, das geht doch bestimmt auch. Aha, anfunktiert der ganze Kram nämlich. Ah,
ich kann das alles Const sein. So, ansonsten müssen wir es an dem Constructor machen, das
ist auch nicht so wild. So, Blablabla, TCP-Client. So, und jetzt müssen wir sagen, in Start
connecte dich mal zum Server, das hat hiermit funktioniert. Oh, das ist so wild, ähm.
Das ist unbedingt, ähm. Kann ich den? So, sowas hier geht nicht, oder? Keine Ahnung,
irgendwie streben, das wird nicht funktionieren, oder? Ne, ne, das geht an der Stelle nicht.
Ist das überhaupt sinnvoll? Ne, es ist immer, es ist besten, ich pack das immer in den extra
Using eigentlich. Wenn ich den Stream dispose vom TCP-Client, kloast er sich dann auch?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, muss ich mal ausprobieren. Das geht doch sicher auch, asynch, ja bestimmt.
Ja, gut, ey, ich krieg das im Chat auch nicht alles immer mit, außerdem ist es doch besser,
ich komm da selbst an der Stelle drauf. Da weiß ich nichts, aber warum das so ist. So,
Blablabla, Startdings, ok. So, jetzt loggen wir uns ein. Gleich, Client, getStream. Jetzt
loggen wir uns hier erstmal ein. Moment, nicht hier, sondern im Blödsinn, sondern hier.
Und hier auch nicht, sondern hier. Hier loggen wir uns erstmal ein. Und zwar damit, haben
wir uns ja schon angeguckt, wie das funktioniert. So, hier loggen wir uns ein. Und dann machen
wir nochmal hier drin das gleiche, was ich bei dem anderen auch mach, um zu gucken, ob
das jetzt mit der Klasse so funktioniert. Und dann machen wir weiter. So, also wir können
so uns schonmal beim Twitch Chat anmelden und Chatnachrichten lesen. Jetzt machen wir
das mit dem Event als nächstes. Ähm, achso, Moment, das da muss ich drin lassen, sonst
geht die Konsole zu. View, Twitch Chat. Ne, brauchen wir nicht. Chat, Start. Das ist jetzt
von der Logik her ordentlich gemacht. Was meckert der hier rum? Function never returns,
ja das ist Absicht. Oh, was, was, was halt für Schmerzen? Achso, Channel, ja klar. Channel
ist Wobblords. Funktioniert, ok. So, und das ist auch in dem Background-Task gestartet,
ich konnte hier Enter drücken oder geht direkt raus. Wir machen da, wir können, wir machen,
wir machen noch ne Stop, aber noch. Ja, da müssen wir uns unsere Main-Loop hier drinnen
dann irgendwie noch so ne, also so ein Cancellation-Token machen. Emotes in der Konsole. Siehste, wo
wir da beim Thema sind, dass Emojis in der Konsole eine ganz wichtige Geschichte sind.
Mein Twitch Emote in der Konsole wäre natürlich absolut Premium, aber dann bräuchte man eine
Konsole mit Bildersupport. Was ja theoretisch im Gnome Terminal ja sogar geht. Ich hab mal
irgendeinen Typ gesehen, der hat's geschafft quasi in den Buffer vom Gnome Terminal aus
der Konsole zu malen und hat sich dann irgendwie so nen Image-Viewer gebaut. Da müssen sie
ja nicht jetzt komplett übertreiben. So, also das Ding. Das Ding läuft. So, also was hat
er gesagt, was wir noch handeln müssen? Ping-Message. Und wir können uns jetzt auch mal überlegen,
ob wir das Reading nicht von Hand machen. War das hier Peak? Nee, wie? Read. Wie hat man
das nochmal ordentlich gemacht? Read und gleich Null glaube ich, ne? Größer Null. Also sprich
immer wenn er... So, dann brauchen wir nen Buffer. Was? Ah, wisst ihr was wir mal ausprobieren
können? Könnte man diese neue Span-Syntax ausprobieren? Wie geht denn das, Span? Aber
Span geht nur, das ist ja quasi nur nen Read-Only-Wrapper irgendwie um nen Array oder wie war das mit
Span? Hab ich mir letztens mal nen Webcast-Tor angeguckt. Ok, byte-array-syntax-insysharp.
So. Scheint ist das richtig. Welches Betriebssystem nutzt Max? Das ist Manjaro. Manjaro Linux
mit i3-WM als Window-Manager. Also in der VM hier. So, bla bla, Buffer. Wenn solange
er was lesen kann, soll er looten. Ja. Oder? Macht man das so? Ich denke man soll, so wird
man das machen. So, und jetzt geben wir mal den Buffer aus. Dass wir müssen den Buffer
erstmal zu nem String umwandeln. Vielleicht ist es mit dem String-Reader doch einfacher.
Aber wir gucken mal, also wie ging das hier? Encoding. Get, oh nee, wie war das umgedrehte
von, von, von, Get-String, so, genau. Get-String-Buffer. Hoch. Buffer? S. So, mal gucken, ob er das jetzt
macht. Yes. So, Leute. Womit? Ja. Nee. Doch, Test funktioniert.
Ja, ich würd sagen funktioniert, oder? Was will er uns immer sagen? Das ist einfach
so ne, so ne, so ne Status-Meldung von Twitch, oder? Vielleicht sollte man den Buffer auch
mal leeren. Was? Der wird immer wieder überschrieben, wozu soll ich den Buffer leeren? Das ist
ja immer der gleiche Buffer, wir liegen ja noch nicht bei irgendwas. Joa. Noch nicht, nee,
so liegen wir auch nix an der Stelle. Aber das ist trotzdem ziemlicher Mist eigentlich,
was ich hier mache, weil wir wollen ja eigentlich nur eine Zeile lesen. Das heißt, wir müssen
jetzt, wir machen das doch mit nem, mit nem Stream-Reader, weil das einfach deutlich handlicher
ist, damit nur eine Zeile, nur eine Zeile zu lesen. Weil jetzt müssten wir eigentlich
sagen, ok, ähm, wie waren wir das? Da muss ich jetzt mal überlegen, wie würden wir das
jetzt gescheit machen? Wir würden jetzt quasi lesen, bis zum nächsten Newline, dann würden
wir in der Zeile gucken, ob da ein Dings drinne steht, ein Priv-Message oder ein Ping. Wenn
ein Ping drinne steht, antworten wir mit Pong. Ich mach das mit nem Stream-Reader, das ist
viel einfacher. Ähm, und wenn jetzt die Message ist, dann geben wir die Message aus. Ja, das
ist das eigentlich Schöne. Weil das ist mit dem, mit dem, mit dem, immer quasi 40069 Speizlesen
ist tatsächlich gar nicht so einfach, weil du liest, du liest in der Regel dann so viel,
wie drinne ist im Buffer jedes Mal. Also du liest, du liest das immer leer quasi, den
Stream. Wieso kein Aquas, weiß ich, weil Twitch sich das ausgedacht hat, dass man Pong
schicken muss. Du musst zu Twitch fragen, warum kein Ack. Ich wollte so keinen, keinen,
keinen Sack-Overflow haben. Gab's ja letztens. Genau, und weil wir lesen ja immer quasi alles
komplett aus dem, aus dem Netzwerk-Stream ein. Das heißt, dann müssten wir uns, dann
müssten wir das scannen bis zum ersten Newline und uns quasi den Rest aufheben für nächsten
Durchgang. Ah ne, wir machen das mit einem Stream-Reader, der macht das alles schon für
uns. Warum soll wir das, warum soll wir das nicht machen? Jetzt, jetzt können wir auch,
jetzt können wir auch ein Using machen dann. So, New Stream-Reader. So, und da können wir
jetzt, wenn nicht End of Stream ist, solange der Stream noch nicht zu Ende ist, lesen wir
einfach jetzt immer mal Zeile für Zeile ein. End, Read, was macht ReadBlock? Ah, okay,
man kann mir eben ansagen von wie viel bis wie viel. Aber wir wollen Readline haben.
Okay, führen wir das Ganze noch mal aus, ob das funktioniert. End of Names, blablabla.
Muss man auf der Chat-Nachricht warten, gucken ob das funktioniert. Machen wir selbst eine.
0, 3D. Jawoll, klappt. Bisschen zu viel C++, ey, ich hab gerade gesagt, das ist unglaublich
schwierig von low-level Arduino-C-Zeugs auf C-Sharp zu switchen. So, und jetzt müssen
wir die Ping-Geschichte noch einbauen. Okay, also wir haben jetzt zur Auswahl hier einmal
Readline. So, und das können wir jetzt sagen, wenn die, wir machen da mal eine eigene Funktion,
wie Scan-Line oder sowas. Muss man überlegen, wie man das ordentlich nennen kann. String-Line-Case-Switch.
Moment, ist die scharf, warte mal, lass mal kurz in mich gehen. Moment, das ging hier gar nicht so, oder?
Nee, nee, Moment, das funktioniert hier gar nicht so. Ich glaub, das muss ich mit dem If machen.
Oh, dieses Klammer-Feature. Line-Contains-Priv-Message. Haben wir den normalen Message. Und wenn die
wenn die Zeile Ping enthält, dann müssen wir Pong antworten. Irgendwie so, ne? Weil das ist so kurz,
können wir auch inline unten machen. Und dann mal gucken, wie man das aufsplitten will. Man
wollte es ja nicht zu lang machen. So, und wenn die Zeile Nachricht enthält, dann geben wir es
einfach aus. Ach ja, Assembler haben wir übrigens auch letztens gemacht. Das war auch ganz lustig,
irgendwie. So, und wenn Ping kommt, geben wir auch mal hier aus. Ping, immer Pong, so wie der das da
auch macht. Und dann muss man den Pong als Antwort zurückschicken. Also müssen wir das hier machen.
Okay. Brauchen wir aber keinen. So, und die Message, die können wir noch splitten. Da muss
ich mir jetzt aber die Ausgabe noch mal angucken, wie das aufgebaut ist,
dass ich das ordentlich splitten kann. Wow. Jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht. Ach ne,
ich filter den anderen Kram ja raus. Aber ich muss warten bis Doppelpunkt. Ich muss den ersten
Doppelpunkt suchen. Sehe ich das richtig? Ja, den ersten Doppelpunkt und danach.
Nein, Contains Ping. Ja, ist klar Leute. Jetzt wollen wir es wieder wissen. Jetzt wird es
wieder getriggert hier. In den ersten Doppelpunkt.
Ah ja, doch klar. Der zweite Doppelpunkt. Den ersten habe ich schon gar nicht gesehen.
Jaja, der zweite Doppelpunkt. Was ist denn das da? Wie kriege ich denn das wieder weg?
Close. Was? Wie kriege ich das weg? Ach, die Database. Okay, also können wir jetzt hier quasi
sagen, Wahr Message ist Line, Partition. Ach ne, Moment, wir sind nicht in Ruby. Ist das mit
Substring gescheit? Wir können splitten am Doppelpunkt und einfach den zweiten nehmen.
Ne, mit Substring funktioniert das Ganze nicht. So was wie First. Gut, wir können sagen Split.
Diese Kammerfeature ist wirklich merkwürdig. Wir können sagen Split und dann am Doppelpunkt.
Kann man sonst noch sagen Separator. Warum wählt er das nicht aus, obwohl er das anzeigt?
Remove Empty Entries. Okay. Wobei, das sollte eigentlich, das ist nicht wild. Wir splitten und
dann wollen wir eigentlich das letzte. Oh no, das müsste doch die Message sein. Ne, ne, ne, Moment.
Wir wollen wirklich am zweiten. Wir wollen wirklich am zweiten, weil sonst schreibt irgendwie
einer Doppelpunkt in der Message und es buggt rum. Wir wollen wirklich, wir wollen wirklich den
zweiten haben. Okay, mal gucken, was das jetzt ausgibt. Das muss ich noch ein bisschen verbessern
mit dem Ping, dass der nicht mehr auf Ping von Ping-Chat-Nachrichten reagiert. So. Ah, Moment mal. Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ich brauch nicht die Eins. Ich brauch, ah, das ist der zweite Eintrag und ich brauch den Eintrag
danach. Okay, ich brauch den zweiten in dem Fall. Test mit Doppelpunkt, Flo. Kannste noch mal machen.
Mach mal. Ah ja, okay. Ah ne, dann muss ich noch den Rest wieder joinen. Da muss ich den Rest noch
joinen gleich. Genau, das funktioniert nämlich nicht. Nehmen wir jetzt nur das zweite. Ich habe
übrigens gelesen, dass es in C-Sharp, ich glaube 8, dass die dann so Range-Selector-Dinger haben,
so wie man das irgendwie so, so wie man das von Ruby und so kennt. Wo ist der Raspberry ja bei der
Post? Oder mit Doppelpunkt, mit Punkt, Punkt, Punkt war es genau. Der ist in Lieferung,
allerdings bis jetzt noch nicht angekommen. Ja, die ist nicht bei der Post, bei DHL ist der. Okay,
wie machen wir das jetzt? Also wir wollen ja nicht das zweite. Eigentlich wollen wir quasi, quasi zwei,
zwei to end, aber ich glaube, das geht so nicht ohne weiteres. Also wie können wir das jetzt,
wie können wir das jetzt ordentlich machen? Wir splitten. Ja, warte mal, lass mal überlegen,
wie machen wir das jetzt ordentlich? Wie macht denn der Python tut das? Der splittet an Doppelpunkt
2. Ja, der hat eine Range-Syntax. Der hat eine Range-Syntax. Wir haben keine Range-Syntax,
also muss man das irgendwie von Hand machen. Da muss man überlegen, wie könnte man das schön,
schön machen, mit Link oder so. Wer ist der Justin Fan-Account nochmal? Ist egal,
einfach Justin Fan mit irgendeiner 5-stelligen Random-Nummer. Kann man nicht sowas sagen hier,
Take und dann, nein, man muss den Count sagen. Gibt es nicht sowas wie Slice oder so? Da muss
irgendwas Schönes geben. Da muss irgendwas Schönes geben. Ich meine, im Zweifelsfall
machen wir ein Regex. Regex geht immer. Wenn sonst nichts geht, geht ein Regex. Substring?
Substring könnten wir machen. Substring machen wir. Das Substring dürfte am schönsten sein.
Wir suchen uns einfach den Index vom zweiten Doppelpunkt und dann machen wir Substring
von dort bis Schluss. Das klingt doch eigentlich ganz sinnig, oder? Mal gucken,
wie wir das jetzt am schönsten machen. Line? Index? Index auf Any? Ja, das können wir machen.
Das ist schön. Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Index und Index auf Any? Index off
ist immer von Anfang an. Und Index auf Any kann ich angeben. Oder? Kann Index off auch
Startindex? Doch, Startindex. Ja, dann ist leider. Wollen wir Index off? Doppelpunkt
wollen wir haben. Und der Startindex ist einfach nicht 0, sondern 1. So, da haben wir den Index
vom zweiten Doppelpunkt. Was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen? Genau, da haben wir den Index vom
zweiten Doppelpunkt jetzt. Die Q, richtig, genau. So, jetzt haben wir den Index vom zweiten
Doppelpunkt und jetzt sagen wir einfach Message gleich Line Substring. Das müsste doch so
funktionieren, oder? Oder liege ich jetzt komplett falsch? Startindex? Index. Und als Länge will
ich, haha, ne, das will ich nicht. Das will ich wahrscheinlich nicht, weil das länger
ist, sondern Length minus Index will ich wahrscheinlich. Oder will ich das? Klingt
doch jetzt erstmal irgendwie plausibel, oder? Habe ich einen Denkfehler drin? Brauchst kein
zweites Argument. Ach, macht er dann automatisch bis Ende? Ach ja, noch viel besser. Das ist
eine Sache, die ich, die habe ich jetzt schon oft in Streams gesagt, nicht mehr machen als
sein muss. Und lieber mal 5 Minuten gucken, ob es was im Framework eingebautes gibt oder
irgendwie schon eine fertige Lösung, die dabei ist, anstatt jetzt irgendwie unnötig
was selber stricken. Okay, bla bla bla, Index. Ein guter Programmierer ist ein fauler Programmierer,
ja, da ist, da ist was dran. Test, haha, es funzt. Ah, Moment, wir müssen eins weiter
starten. Wir müssen Index plus 1 oder irgendwie sowas starten, weil jetzt ist der Doppelpunkt
dabei. Ah ja, das passt schon. Wir müssen übrigens auch noch abfragen, sollte nichts
gefunden werden, wobei wir uns da bei ISC wahrscheinlich darauf verlassen können, weil
diese Sachen halt immer so aufgebaut sind. Also Index plus 1. So eine viel schönere
Lösung als das alles zu splitten und dann wieder zu joinen, oder? Name, ja, das mache
ich dann. Du könntest bei den Nachrichten einen Doppelpunkt am Ende machen und dann?
Wenn jemand Ping spammt, passiert gar nichts gerade. Das müssen wir uns als nächstes
angucken, wie das aussieht. Warum ist Line unterstrichen, gute Frage. Ah, weil ich nicht
checke, ob Line 0 ist. Aber ich verlasse mich da jetzt in dem Fall mal drauf. Ich meine,
ich sage hier Read-Line und der wird ja nicht Crap-Readen. Also das ist glaube ich eher
was, wo es theoretisch möglich wäre, dass es 0 ist, aber praktisch wird es wahrscheinlich
nicht vorkommen. Ach ja, das wird natürlich auch funktionieren, Tommy, du hast ja Recht.
Habe ich die falsche C-Sharp-Version ausgewählt? Warum funktioniert das nicht? Es sollte doch
eigentlich funktionieren. Ah, ja Moment, das funktioniert nicht, weil ich jetzt quasi
einen, wie heißt es, Nullable-Dings zurückkriege. Weil es könnte ja, in dem Fall könnte es
quasi True, False oder Null sein. Nee, nee, da wird kein, ähm, ähm, das ist, das ist
dieser, dieser, wie heißt das, dieser, äh, nicht, äh, wenn nicht Null-Operator. Also
quasi, der führt Contains nur aus, wenn, äh, Line nicht Null ist. Allerdings, wenn
du es in einem If verwendest, der Rückgabewert ist quasi ein, genau, so Nullable-Ding. Da
kommt dann quasi ein Typ raus, der dann, der könnte, der könnte quasi Null, True oder
False sein. Das heißt, ich müsste jetzt hier noch gucken, so nach dem Motto, ähm, wie
guckt man das eigentlich? Value? Nö. Äh, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung. Aber es ist
an der Stelle auch ziemlich überflüssig. Äh, Flo, du willst lachen? Ich hab genau
an das gleiche gerade gedacht. Ich hab mir gerade auf diesen Ping geguckt und hab mir
gedacht, eigentlich ist es egal, wie oft einer Ping spammt, weil das If greift gar nicht,
wenn es der Message ist. Das geht? Äh. Ach so, Moment. Ah ja, doch, ja doch, doch, das
ergibt sogar Sinn, dass das funktioniert. Das ist ja Dings-Operator hier, Null, Null-Dings.
Boah, frag mich nicht, wie das, wie das heißt. Der quasi guckt, ähm, wo du so die Fault-Werte
setzen kannst. Ist die linke Seite Null, dann nehm das. Das ist so die, das ist so die Kurzform
von dem hier. Bloß, dass du da halt nur ein, ja, das hier ist quasi die If-Els-Variante
und das hier ist nur die If-Null-Variante. Aber find ich trotzdem nicht so dolle. Zumal
das ja nicht Null ist. Wenn der Reader readet, dann ist das auch nicht Null. Genau, und hier
können wir eigentlich den Ping wieder einkommentieren und ihr könnt so oft Ping schreiben, wie ihr
wollt, das kommt nie an dieser Stelle an. Können wir mal ausprobieren. Könnt ihr mal
Ping schreiben? Der pingt, der pingt nie. Der pingt nicht, nöpp. Macht er nicht, da schreibt
nur eure Message hin. Ok, also, so die, also das funktioniert prinzipiell. Jetzt können
wir das mit den Events machen. Sagen wir machen jetzt hier ein Event. Public Event, Action,
genau, String. Wie nennen wir denn das? Received Message. Da kann man sich subscriben. Und hier
drin schmeißen wir einfach, schmeißen wir einfach in Volkmessage. So, jetzt wirft, jetzt
wirft unser, unser Twitch Chat Received Messages auf dem Event. Das ist doch, jede Message
haut da raus mit, haut ein Event raus, sobald eine Message ankommt. Und die kann ich jetzt
woanders verarbeiten. Das ist doch eigentlich genau das was wir haben wollen. Wenn man das
natürlich dann in irgendeinem GUI oder so einsetzt, da muss man wieder ein bisschen
aufpassen, weil Events laufen immer im Thread vom Aufrufer. Also sprich, wenn ich das hier
jetzt subscribe, das Event, wo ich jetzt hier in meinem GUI Programm wäre und das Event
wird ausgelöst, dann läuft das Event nicht in meinem GUI Thread, wenn das hier ein GUI
wäre, sondern hier in diesem Worker Thread. Was dann bei einem GUI dazu führen würde,
dass es entweder nicht geht, hängen bleibt oder irgendwelche Exceptions gibt, weil falscher,
falscher Caller. Gibt es eigentlich sowas wie concurrent Events? Ähm, du meinst Events,
die, die, die irgendwie zeitgleich sein können oder so? Also, ich, ja klar, ja klar, ich
hab ja gerade gesagt, das Event wird im Kontext, ähm, vom Ursprungs, vom, vom, vom auslösenden
Thread aufgerufen, so. Und wenn du jetzt hier, ähm, wenn du jetzt hier drei Threads dran
arbeiten hast, die zufälligerweise alle zeitgleich das hier aufrufen, dann wird das auch zeitgleich,
äh, auf, wird das auch zeitgleich invoked. Und das Subscriben, der kann sich dagegen
überhaupt nicht wehren. Das wird einfach aufgerufen, das muss überhaupt nicht, das
hat überhaupt nichts mit dem Kontext vom Subscriber zu tun. Also, ja, das würde dann tatsächlich
zeitgleich getriggert werden oder nahezu zeitgleich, paar Nanosekunden oder so, je nachdem,
aber exakt zeitgleich wird es nicht hinkriegen. Auch Multiswap nicht, das ist zu, zu, zu
random. Aber doch, die, die, die sind eigentlich Konkurrent. Also Events ist glaub ich nichts
dabei, was das irgendwie verbietet, dass es irgendwie zeitgleich auftreten kann. Wenn
du, wenn du unterschiedliche Threads hast, die das Event werfen, werfen die das auch
exakt zur gleichen Zeit. Deswegen musst du ja auch drauf achten, wenn du so nen, so
nen, wie nennt man das so schön, so nen Producer-Consumer-Pattern hast, dass du es
dann irgendwie in ne Warteschlange queest, dass der Typ, der's verarbeitet, in dem Fall
dann dein GUI-Thread, dass der das in ner ordentlichen Reihenfolge abruft, die irgendwie
sinnvoll ist für den Task, den du hast. Also die, die Events sind eigentlich immer Konkurrent.
Du musst gucken, dass du das eigentlich eher umgedreht, du musst handeln, dass die Konkurrent
sind. Trotzdem ist unser Twitch-Chat jetzt in der Lage, Events zu werfen. Bei ner neuen
Message. Okay, das ist doch schon mal schön. Ach ja, den Name sollten wir vielleicht noch.
Da muss ich jetzt nochmal kurz angucken, wie das ausgesehen hat. Mit dem, ne komplette
Teile muss ich mir nochmal angucken, wie das ausgesehen hat mit dem Namen. Da hat er geschrieben,
der X-Shadow-Gast hat High geschrieben, so. Äh, okay, nach dem ersten Doppelpunkt, also
der Name kommt quasi direkt am Anfang, gefolgt von nem Ausrufezeichen. Also im Prinzip können
wir immer sagen, von Index 1, also von Index 1 bis zum Ausrufezeichen. Wow, sieht doch
eigentlich ganz brauchbar aus. Kopieren wir uns mal so ne Zeile, dass wir uns das angucken
können. Okay, Message, so, und das heißt User, User ist dann, warum macht er da, was,
was, ey, was tut er da? Alter, was, was macht er? User gleich Line, so, Sub, ah, Moment
mal, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, mit Substring funktioniert's nicht direkt, sondern erst wenn
wir das First, wie könnte man das möglichst elegant machen? Wir können uns das Index
vom Ausrufezeichen holen, aber irgendwie gefällt mir das nicht. Ist da nicht irgendwas Schönes
eingebautes? Habt ihr hier ne clevere Idee? Ansonsten machen wir das wieder mit dem Index
wie vorher. Place. Ja, mit dem Split könnte man das machen, das ist eigentlich keine schlechte
Idee in dem Fall, weil wir könnten wirklich einfach sagen, Split, Split an Ausrufezeichen
und dann das da. Dann haben wir den, dann haben wir aber allerdings den, glaub den Doppelpunkt
noch mit drinne. Kannst auch extension, jaja klar, klar. Wobei das mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht so sehr stört, wenn da noch ein Doppelpunkt drinne ist, wenn ich das am Ende
abhaken muss. Okay, was, also das wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren, da muss den Doppelpunkt irgendwie
los werden. Kann man, kann man nicht irgendwie remove, replace? Ey, wie viele Methoden hat
Substring eigentlich? Getrim? Nee, das ist Widespace. Einer Doppelpunkt ist hier, ja
da bleibt aber der Text immer noch übrig. Substring 1. Dann hab ich einen Doppelpunkt.
Aha. No documentation. Ja gut, dann Trim da vorne und hinten halt einzelne Chars, allerdings
das bringt nichts. Nee, dann lassen wir das jetzt so, wie es hier, wie es da Flo glaube
ich vorgeschlagen hat mit Split. Das ist eigentlich ganz, ganz gut. Das könnten wir lassen. Wir
könnten jetzt bloß noch sagen, dass wir den, dass wir quasi das löschen, dass wir quasi
alles ab eins wegschmeißen, so. Also ohne, ohne eins. Wobei es eigentlich fast schöner
wäre, den replacen. Kann man replace sagen, dass der nur das erste replacet? Nee, gell.
Kann man? Kann ich ihm irgendwie sagen, replace mir nur, replace character an index position
1 mit einem anderen Zeichen? Geht das? Was? Split? Substring 1. Macht das gleiche wie
remove 1, oder? Ja. Im Prinzip ist es gleich wie, weiß ich nicht, remove. Ja, warte mal,
remove macht das nicht, ist, begin at a specified, wahrscheinlich index oder so. So im Prinzip
ist es gleich, oder? Ja, jetzt ist der Doppelpunkt weg. Aber was mache ich denn, wenn ich das
replacen will? Also mal angenommen, ich will den Doppelpunkt replacen. Stimmt ja. In dem
Fall ist es tatsächlich relativ einfach. Wir machen einfach replace, weil ich habe
ja nur den ersten. Genau. Dann mache ich einfach replace. Na gut, was passiert eigentlich,
wenn jemand im Namen Doppelpunkt hat? Wird er dann auch replaced? Darf man Doppelpunkte
in Namen haben? Ah, bei replace kann man count, nee, kann man nicht. Ach, geht nicht, okay.
Na gut, dann kann man sagen, replace Doppelpunkt mit. So, dann müssen wir uns ja noch irgendwie
ein schönes Zeichen ausdenken, für das ich weiß, von wem es ist. Was könnte man da nehmen?
Ich weiß, wer der Absender ist. Ach, scheiß drauf, komm. Wir löschen jetzt alles aus,
was dem Doppelpunkt gut ist. User, invoke message. Okay, dann müssen wir unser Event
noch anpassen mit, keine Ahnung, string, string, das ist jetzt nicht so schön. Wir haben hier
user message. Also wir sollten da den eigenen Typ für basteln, dass man weiß, was was ist.
Ja, aber ich mein, im Prinzip funktioniert das eigentlich jetzt schon nochmal, würde
ich sagen, ganz gut. Können wir mal ausprobieren. Chat, receive message. Ach, Moment, da darf
man nicht einfach enter drücken. Ah, so, und da haben wir jetzt hier user, user, und user,
message. Ah, haben wir, cw, user, message. So, und jetzt kriegen wir quasi für jede
message den Event mit dem User drin und der Message drin. Gut, dieses Geschwubbel ist,
das können wir nochmal löschen. Genau, der diet hat tryhard geschrieben, und der deadlift
hat poggi geschrieben. Das ist doch schön. So, dann machen wir das Geschwubbel hier weg.
War ja nur Debug. Das machen wir auch nicht, das wird unter der Haube schon funktionieren,
hoffe ich. Gut, so, und da haben wir eine Twitch-Chat-Klasse, die genau vom Prinzip her das macht, was
wir haben wollen, nämlich checkt, wer was geschrieben hat im Chat, und jetzt müssen
wir nur noch gucken, das können wir ja theoretisch in unserem Event-Händler machen. Jetzt können
wir mal gucken, ob dort in der message, ob dort in der message, quasi, irgendwo bloß
drin steht. Das typo in string. Muss man add escape eigentlich net, oder? So, und nur
wenn Adwoblots drin steht, oh das Verschieben von Zeilen geht hier nicht, nur wenn Adwoblots
drin steht, dann schreiben wir einfach rein. Neue Frage, und zwar von User irgendwas, von
dem User mit dieser Message. So, probieren wir mal aus. Genau, SilentPain hat gefragt,
wie das mit Ayaya aussieht. Sebaro fragt, DHL hat noch 30 Minuten Zeit für das Paket.
Wonka S. jetzt sagt, hey, ja, nice. Das reicht doch schon. Das reicht doch im Prinzip schon.
Wir können das natürlich jetzt ein bisschen schöner machen, zum Beispiel, dass man sagt,
ja, man macht das so, dass man noch einzelne Sachen löschen kann. Was? Nightbot exkludiert
Adwoblots? Äh, letztendlich, also mich hätt's gewundert, wenn das nicht schon irgendwo
fertig eingebaut wäre. Aber mich hat mal interessiert, wie man es selbst macht. Ähm, du hast vollkommen
recht, der Detlef, natürlich. Ähm, wir sollten noch, wir sollten hier noch reinschreiben,
message to, oh, ich debugge auch gar nicht mehr. To lower sollten wir hier reinschreiben,
ja, das ist richtig. Genau, und jetzt müsste man, das stimmt, was der Matt sagt, hab ich
mir auch schon dran gedacht, wir könnten das jetzt noch ein bisschen verfeinern, indem
wir zum Beispiel sagen können, man kann das irgendwie abhaken. Also quasi die, die Sachen,
die ich erledigt hab, wie leuchtet den ping, würde er auch pong schicken, wenn's ne private
message ist? Nee, macht er nicht, weil er zuerst guckt, ob's ne message ist, und danach
guckt, ob's, ob's ein ping ist. Äh, wodurch wird dir der Parameter-Name im Konstruktor-Aufruf
angezeigt? Meinst du das da? Äh, das macht Rider anscheinend so. Ich benutze das heute
mehr oder weniger zum ersten Mal. Das scheint die default setting in Rider zu sein. Guck
mal, so geiler Nightbot. Den könnten wir übrigens noch filtern. Den könnten wir noch
filtern, weil das wird das ganze ziemlich, ziemlich voll spammen, der Nightbot. And
user nicht Nightbot. Ähm, ja oder genau, ReSharper in Virtual Studio geht auch, damit
hat der Kram ja quasi so angefangen damals. Das war so glaub ich eines der ersten Sachen,
die ich von denen gesehen hab. Oder haben die das nicht sogar auch gekauft? War ReSharper
von Anfang an von JetBrains? Der Nightbot, ja. Der arme Nightbot. Joa, genau, jetzt
fehlt uns jetzt noch so was, wo man sagen kann, ja okay, die Sache hab ich beantwortet.
Ja, ich weiß, dass ReSharper JetBrains ist, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, war das von
Anfang an JetBrains? Weil ich kann mich noch an irgendwie 2005 oder so erinnern, wo die
Leute alle was mit ReSharper erzählt haben. Das war so das erste, was ich von denen gesehen
hab. Die haben, die hatten auch ein ganz cooles, ähm,.NET Reflektor Programm mal. Gucken,
ob es das noch gibt. Ja, entscheidend nicht, aber es könnte sein, dass das den Rider eingebaut
ist. Ja, aber ich finde, das ist ganz cool. So, was wir jetzt nicht in der Konsolenanwendung
mehr machen können, ist, dass wir hier sagen können, okay, diese Frage hab ich schon beantwortet.
Das ist in der Konsolenanwendung doof. Was wir machen könnten, ist, wir könnten uns
die ganzen Messages in einem Error speichern und kriegt quasi jede Sache, jede Nummer
davor und ich mach ne Eingabe, so nach dem Motto, ey, lösche mir jetzt Nummer 5. Warum
machen wir das eigentlich? So ein kracher ne blöde Idee, oder? Das ist an sich relativ
simpel. Das ist an sich relativ simpel und, äh, wäre doch eigentlich ausreichend, ne?
Einfach sagen, ja, das ist Frage 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, irgendwas und wenn ich das beantwortet
habe, gebe ich einfach ein, ah, okay, Frage 1 beantwortet, bam. Gibt bestimmt irgendwo
ne Konsole GUI. Jaja, garantiert. Aber ich, ich, ich möchte das möglichst, möglichst
einfach, einfach halten, ein ordentliches GUI, können wir dem zumindest nicht verpassen,
solang es Cross-Plattform sein soll, das ist ja nicht so, nicht so einfach. Zumindest
nicht mit, mit.NET aktuell. Mir fehlen ordentliche Qt-Bindings für, für.NET. Das wäre ne super,
eine super Kombination. Hallo, der Eaxe ist auch am Start, nice. Da hätte man ordentliche
Cross-Plattform-GUI für euch. Ja, Webinterface ist total oversize dafür, zu den Webinterfaces.
Ja, Webinterface ist total overkill. Da brauch ich dann extra Tab mit irgendwas und, wobei,
näher, wobei man sagen muss, nen, nen, so nen, rudimentäres Webinterface, was die Sachen
untereinander anzeigen, wo ich Sachen löschen kann, das könnte man auch im Stream einpländen.
Das lässt sich nämlich relativ einfach Captchern dann. Und, dann sieht man, dass, dass seine
Frage nicht vergessen wurde. Und ich glaub, das ist in so Labastreams gar nicht schlecht,
dass man dann quasi im Stream so ne Fragen-Q hat, die noch offen sind. Oder was sagt ihr?
Das ist doch eigentlich, für mich klingt das, klingt das clever. Das quasi so zu machen,
dass man's einbauen kann im Stream. Mach's in die Overlay-App. Oh nee, da hat es eigentlich
nix drin zu suchen. 5x5-NED-Matrix soll, ja, dann seht ihr's ja nicht. Das, das Ganze
dann wie mit Webcam abfilmen. Als OBS-Python-Plugin. Das ist voll, voll Overkill dafür. Ich mein,
wir müssten es ja auch nicht als Webinterface machen, wir könnten es halt als jemand anderes
machen. Also ich kann auch einfach nen Konsolen-Window Captchern. Der Stream, der Steam-Summer-Sendung
von, oh da müssen wir mal gucken. Da müssen wir mal gucken, was es gibt, Leute. Ah, Steam.
Gucken, gucken wir mal kurz drüber, was, was da, was da gibt gerade. Aber wahrscheinlich
ist eh wieder nix dabei, was mich irgendwie, äh, sondern nicht schockt. Halt ich keinen
Bock drauf. Hab ich eigentlich auch keinen grossartigen Bock drauf. Hab ich mir im Vorfeld
schonmal angeguckt und wird es öfters empfohlen, interessiert mich auch nicht großartig. Ähm,
juckt mich null. Hä, ist Left4Dead? Die Typen sehen original aus wie Left4Dead?
Das ist doch das Left4Dead Squad. Haben die das gerippt oder was? Das sind doch die Left4Dead
Typen. Das hier Dings Bill und, und, und, und, und, und, Dings, ich hab Zoey und, und,
äh, Coach. Die hießen auch so. Ja, das sind, hä? The fuck? Warum, warum sind die Left4Dead
Dudes da drinnen und, und Mädels? Oh Mann. Den fällt aber auch sonst nix mehr ein, oder?
Was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde ist, ist es was Autorisiertes? Ach, okay, das ist
wahrscheinlich wirklich was Autorisiertes. Na, okay. Juckt mich trotzdem nicht. Zombie
Games sind, sind, äh, ja, übelst Resident Sleeper. Was haben wir noch hier? Oh, das
ist was für unsere Weepfans. Es sieht aber zumindest grafisch wirklich hübsch aus. Oder
auch nicht. Das blört wie verrückt. Okay, es ist Early Access. Nope. Äh, sieht auch
nicht so aus, als juckt es mich. Juckt mich auch nicht. Das wollte ich mir mal angucken.
Bin ich nie dazu gekommen bisher. Äh, juckt mich nicht. Juckt mich überhaupt nicht. Oh,
noch mehr. Moment, es gibt, Moment, was? Das gibt es mittlerweile auf dem PC? Irgendwie
30 Jahre oder so nach Release? Warum gibt es Chrono Trigger irgendwie 25 Jahre nach
Release auf dem PC? Und, und warum sieht es, warum sieht es schlechter aus als im SNES
Emulator? Das ist das Game aus dem meine, meine Outro Musik ist. Oder die ich öfters
mal spiele. Ähm, warum gibt es das auf dem PC? Was ist, was ist mit Square Enix los?
Ich meine, es ist nicht schlimm, dass es das auf dem PC gibt. Das ist wirklich ein sehr
gutes Game, ja. Wer es noch nicht gespielt hat, soll es sich das unbedingt mal geben.
Aber man sieht es halt, man sieht es der Sache halt an. Es ist ein Super Nintendo Spiel
und es sieht auch aus wie ein Super Nintendo Spiel. Und es sieht schlechter aus als in
einem Emulator. Gucke ich mal an, wie die, wie die, die Verlauf von den Linien stimmt
überhaupt nicht. Nee, nee, nee. Rollenspiele, juck ich war das nicht. Oh, der Football Manager
2019, ja das ist genau das was ich mir unter einem Rollenspiel vorstelle. Sagt mir auch
Null. Ist das so ein, sieht ein bisschen aus wie Shadow of the Colossus, bloß mit Grill
und mit Survival. Oh nee, Kleiter, Kleiter ist schon mal gar nichts. So, was haben wir
sonst noch vorgestellt? Juckt mich alles nicht, juckt mich alles nicht. Das soll ganz nice
sein, habe ich gelesen. Insurgency Sandstorm, ich weiß. Eax, hast du das jetzt mal weitergespielt?
Da war noch Free Weekend. Würdest du sagen das taugt? Aber ich hab schon, ich hab mir
das schon gekauft vor einer Weile. Insurgency Sandstorm, Farming Simulator, Sniper Elite,
Wolfenstein haben wir auch schon alles gespielt. GTA, wie oft wollen sie das noch melken? Juckt
mich alles nicht, juckt mich auch alles nicht. Moment, das hatten wir doch schon. Ark juckt
mich überhaupt nicht, hab ich schon, hab ich auch schon. Ich hab irgendwie alles was
mich juckt schon. So, noch mehr Ayaya, hab ich auch schon. Weiß ich gar nicht wie sich
das mittlerweile entwickelt hat, das Game. Back Ops The Line, ja hab ich gespielt, hab
ich durchgespielt, fand ich ziemlich gut. Nicht vom Gameplay und den Mechaniken her,
sondern von der Aussage her hinter dem Game, fand ich ganz gut. Die Story war ein bisschen
Confuse. Was hat jetzt ne Story? Der Ability ist okay. Das hab ich schon, mir würde interessieren
wie die Bewertungen gerade so sind. Immer das Zeug da. Also bei manchen Sachen ist es
gerechtfertigt ja, aber oftmals sind es dann Leute, die dann ins offizielle Forum gehen
und dann reinschreiben irgendwie Dead Game Fucking Ass Gameplay You Suck Never Develop Game
Again oder irgendwie sowas und dann sich wundern, wenn der Post geschlossen wird.
Aber auf der anderen Seite neigen auch viele Hersteller dazu jeden Mist zu closen, das will
ich ja auch nicht befürworten. Juckt mich alles nicht. Wie das Bass? Er ist nicht im
Spiel. Juckt mich alles nicht. Wieso kopierst du manchmal random Stuff? Oh da haben wir
ein Kommando für, ich weiß aber gerade nicht, wie das Kommando ist. Der Sebaro da? Der Sebaro
ist da. Sebaro du weißt doch bestimmt das Kommando für die Erklärung, warum ich manchmal
random Zeugs kopiere. Da muss ich das nicht nochmal erklären. Riktik? Nee, das war irgendwas
anderes oder? Wenn der Sebaro wieder da ist. Eins! Ausrufezeichen eins, genau. Also wortwörtlich
das, was der Max da so treibt. Juckt mich alles nicht, was es hier gibt. Es gibt keine
Games die mich interessieren. Das ist echt frustrierend. Obwohl ich gerne was spielen
würde. Aber irgendwie interessiert es mich nicht. Hab ich bei Streams schon gesehen,
das ist für unsere Fans ganz gut. Das war so ein bisschen Castlevania. Jetzt hab ich beim
Lost mal gesehen, das ist doch auch ein komisches Battle Royale Mobile Game. Juckt mich überhaupt
nicht. My Friend Pedro. What the fuck? Na, Sidescroll Action hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Monster Hunter World. Was ist da draus eigentlich geworden? Das ist ja mit relativ viel Hype
gestartet. Ist das noch? Ist das dead? Ist das dead oder spielen das noch viele? Okay.
Loading, please. Was ich bei dem Game nie verstanden hab, ist, wie gesagt, ich hab's
ja selbst nicht. Wollte es mit dem Friseur eigentlich spielen, aber der war dann zu sehr
BDO beschäftigt. Was ich bei dem Game nie verstanden hab oder was für mich sich aus
Streams nie so richtig rauskristallisiert hat. Ist das jetzt eher ein Singleplayer Spiel?
Eher ein Koop Spiel? Moment, was zum Teufel macht der Witcher da? Oder ist das ein MMO?
Was macht Geralt da? Was macht der da? Warum ist der in dem Game? Ah, okay, das ist nicht
zu crossover. Ja, Monster Hunter. Stimmt, dafür ist er eigentlich richtig, ne? Ja, und das
sind die Final Fantasy XIV Dudes. Ist das nicht, das ist, nee. Nee, das sind die Monster
Hunter Dudes. Sah ein bisschen aus wie die Final Fantasy Online Typen. Doch, klar, sind
das die, das sind, das sind die, das ist die Default Final Fantasy Online Party, die sie
immer in ihren Trailern drin haben. Okay, und Ciri springt da auch rum. Gut, die haben
einfach wild, wild, ähm, Dinger getrieben da. Was ist denn nur mit Geralt los? Also es ist
eher ein Koop Spiel, kein MMO, sagt ihr. Also wäre das eigentlich genau das Richtige,
das ich mal mit dem Friseur spielen könnte. Jetzt nicht unbedingt on stream, weil das
wahrscheinlich ziemlich langweilig ist. Geralt von Nvidia, oh der war schlecht. Man meldet
sich da erstmal wieder zurück, der meldet sich öfters mal bei sich im Stream zurück,
ja, mach mal hier Ausrufezeichen, Friseur, da ist ein Link drin zu seinem Stream, wobei
der Silent Pain, du kennst, du kennst das doch. Hallo, ich bräuchte dir weiter auf die Seite.
Okay, das sind wieder irgendwelche, weiß nicht, so irgendwelche Games, die mich auch nicht
jucken, so, so Dinge, so Games, die quasi zu hunderten auf Steam spawnen irgendwie und
dann da sind und eigentlich keinen interessieren. Und zum größten Teil sind das Ayaya Games,
wenn ich mir das da schon angucke, das ist eindeutig Ayaya Game. Wow, ein Prozent, safe,
ein Prozent, yeah. Das ist, das ist, das ist wahrscheinlich auch irgendein Ayaya Musikgame
oder so und auch nur in Japanisch, jawoll. Wie stehst du zu Halo auf PC mit dem Gamepass?
Ich finde das gut, dass Halo auf dem PC kommt. Hallo, Laden, Blitz. Das ist alles im Steam
oder was? Top Selling, Top Selling. Nee, gibt es nicht eine Seite, wo alles Sales-Sachen
drin sind oder muss man das Steam für aufmachen? Ah, das ist der SteamDB, Leute, mein Chat,
der kennt sich aus. Ach, hier sieht man das, das ist doch schön. Ähm, das habe ich mir
auch vor einer Weile mal gekauft, nie gespielt, soll auch nicht schlecht sein. Juckt mich
nicht, juckt mich nicht, vielleicht, vielleicht, ähm, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich eigentlich
auch nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob das gut geworden ist. Vielleicht, vielleicht, die alten Bridge-Bilder-Dinger
waren eigentlich ganz cool. Juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht. Habe ich schon auf zig
Plattformen plus Emulator gespielt, muss ich auf dem PC-Dinger mal spielen, vor allem,
wenn es auf dem Emulator besser aussieht. Killing Floor 2 juckt mich nicht, ARK juckt
mich nicht, äh, juckt mich alles nicht, Witcher habe ich schon. Death's Order habe ich auch
schon. Ähm, Dawn's Staff juckt mich auch nicht, Humblaut juckt mich auch nicht, Celeste juckt
mich auch nicht, weil das relativ gut sein soll. Kennst du schon Shenzhen I.O.? Ja,
I.O. Shenzhen klingt nach, klingt nach diesem, ähm, China, ähm, China Technik Dorf. Phantasy
Girl, oh, da haben wir wieder, da haben wir wieder hier für unsere, äh, Anime-Fans ist
das was hier. Oh, seh ich da Tentakel? Seh ich da Tentakel im Hintergrund gerade? Habe
ich da, habe ich da schleimige Tentakel gesehen? Warum? Steam, warum? Äh, ich hab mein Games
auch schon, Oriental Sin 2 habe ich auch, Dungeons 3 hat mich enttäuscht im Vergleich
zum Vorgang, hat mir immer so viel Spaß gemacht, Borderlands habe ich schon, Star Wars juckt
mich nicht, Devil May Cry juckt mich auch nicht, no more Star Wars, boah, ey, das ja,
Release, 25 Jahre, boah, Leute, ernsthaft, ist World at War wirklich schon 11, ist das
schon 11 Jahre her? Ja klar, 2008, oder? Scheiße, ist das lang her. Die wollen immer
noch 10 Euro dafür haben. Und das im Sale. Shadow Warrior, oh, das, das ist, das ist cool,
sowohl der erste als der zweite, das hat Spaß gemacht. Valkyrie 3, cool, das habe ich auch
schon 5 mal durchgespielt oder so, oder mehr, ähm, 193 WTF, kann doch nicht sein, dass da
193 Seiten im Sale sind, das ist ja fast alles im Sale, ne, wobei fast alles nicht, äh,
kompletter Steam-Katalog sind wahrscheinlich 19.000 Seiten oder sowas. Also, manche Spiele
würde ich mir holen, wenn sie minus 100 Prozent hätten. Und manche Spiele sind mit minus
100 Prozent auch noch zu teuer. Kann das sein, dass es unglaublich viele Weep Games gibt?
Irgendwie ist da nichts dabei. Aber wo wir wieder beim alten Problem sind, es gibt keine
Spiele, die mich so richtig begeistern, deswegen spiele ich auch so wenig. Und es liegt gar
nicht daran, dass ich nicht spielen will. Ich würde gerne wieder das übelste Grind Game
haben, was ich quasi jeden Tag spielen will bis zum Umfallen und ähm, wo es mich dann
sogar ärgert, dass ich oft muss. Also sowas würde ich schon gerne wieder haben, ja, aber
eben gibt es das nicht. Minecraft, ja, genau. WoW garantiert nicht. WoW ist nicht meins
und garantiert schon nicht im aktuellen Zustand. Vielleicht wird WoW Classic was, allerdings,
wenn ich schon höre, dass es keine deutschsprachigen Server geben soll, oder was habe ich noch
gelesen, dass die angeblich ihr komisches Server Phasing für Classic verwenden wollen.
Äh, da habe ich da eigentlich schon keinen Bock mehr drauf. GTA Roleplay. Ich will ordentlich
bashen und nicht Roleplayen. Hast du eine VR-Brille? Nö. Gab noch nichts an VR, was mich so interessiert
hat, dass ich gesagt hätte, ich will eine VR-Brille haben. WoW Private Server, ja, habe
ich gemacht. Ich habe gespielt auf Nostalrius ein bisschen, dann haben sie den Server dicht
gemacht und auf dem, auf diesem Nachfolger waren Instan im Chat nur Spasten und da habe
ich nicht weiter gespielt. Ja, so Roleplaying ist nichts für mich. Ich will, wenn ich so
ein Spiel spiele, ich will da drin gut werden, wenn es mir Spaß macht und ich will bashen,
Roleplayen. Will da einloggen, ich will mich queueen und dann will ich die Gegner bashen.
Ich würde ja Overwatch spielen, wenn es nicht immer noch so viele Punkte hätte, die mir
auf den Sack gehen. Und da wird sich auch nie was dran ändern. Die einzige Sache, wo
ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass sich Overwatch zum besseren wandelt ist, wenn Blizzard ihre
eSport Kontrollwarn aufgibt, was sie nicht machen werden. Wobei der Zug auch schon abgefahren
ist mittlerweile irgendwie. Und wenn es vielleicht einen Map-Editor gibt, dass die Leute, und
ich meine damit nicht den Workshop, sondern wo man richtig neue Maps machen kann, komplett
neue Maps, die einfach besser sind als die offiziellen Maps, dann könnte das was werden.
Ich bin mir sicher, wenn du den Leuten erlauben würdest, Overwatch Maps zu machen, die Overwatch
Community würde bessere Maps produzieren als Blizzard das kann. Weil manche Maps in
Overwatch fragen sich echt, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben. Ich meine, guckt euch die 2Cp
Map an mit dem Spawn am letzten Punkt. Das mag zwar irgendwie, wenn man ganz groß ausholt
und irgendwie balanced sein, weil beide Seiten spielen müssen und bla und hin und her, aber
das fühlt sich nicht irgendwie rewarding an, das fühlt sich einfach nur dämlich an, dass
man einen Spawn 2cm hinter einen Capture-Punkt setzt. Das müsste so ein bisschen wie ein
CS sein, wo es quasi so einen offiziellen Competitive Map Pool quasi gibt, die dann
gespielt werden und die auch ab und zu mal wechseln. Aber im CS kommt ja auch immer mal
öfters was dabei. Nicht ganz so restriktiv, ich meine CS, die spielen ja teilweise 10
Jahre am Stück die 3 gleichen Maps. Doch ich glaube, das wird in Overwatch gut funktionieren.
Ich glaube, die Community macht in jedem Game bessere Maps als der Hersteller, wenn
sie die Möglichkeit für hat. Also die, die wirklich Hardcore dann auch Ranked, Grinden,
die wissen auch, was es ankommt. Und die würden so komische 2CP-Maps wie Hanamura
nicht basteln. Es gäbe dann zu viele Troll-Maps, die musst du ja nicht spielen. In CS gibt
es auch 50 Milliarden Maps, die keine interessieren. Du musst dann halt gucken, auf was du dich
einigst als Competitive Pool an Maps. Und da kann er ruhig ab und zu mal wechseln. Da
nimmst du dir halt mal 10 gute Maps raus und tauschst ein bisschen durch. Das machen sie
in CS genauso. Egal, es ist beim Steam-Sale irgendwie nichts bei, was mich juckt, was
ich jetzt so gesehen habe. Und 193 Seiten will ich auch nicht durchgucken. Ne, also
Steam hab ich nicht auf. Keine Ahnung, aber die Seite von Steam hat öfters auch schon
Timeouts. So wie jetzt. Die ganzen Geier stürzen sich gerade auf den Sale. Auf den Sale gegeiert.
Uno für 2,99€. Brauch ich. Uno. Kenn das noch jemand, wo wir Uno mit dem Fabian oder
Sylvaner auf der Xbox gespielt haben? Sie haben Post, ja da. Ubisoft Uno. Sylvaner zeigt
gar nichts. Ich glaub, die ist gerade in London und macht da Dinger. Keine Ahnung, schon ewig
nichts davon gehört. Das Uno ist ziemlich... Wie schafft man es, ein verbuggtes Uno raus
zu bringen? Das ist so, wie wenn ich ein verbuggtes, keine Ahnung, Mensch ärgerlich nicht basteln
würde. Das sind doch jetzt alle Spiele mit keiner super komplexen Logik und technischen
Anforderungen. Wie schafft man es, Uno verbuggt zu bringen? Geht doch gar nicht. Mixed. Ernsthaft.
Das schwebt den Leuten so vor, dass die Leute überall die RL-Bildchen drin haben und auch
so die hipster RL-Bildchen. Nein, echt sieht das eher so aus. Warum hat das schlechte Bewertung?
Das wahrscheinlich ist wirklich verbuggt. Buggie piece of shit. Also okay, Ubisoft hat
anscheinend wirklich geschafft, ein kaputtes Uno raus zu bringen. Ne, ne. Ja, die größten
Schnäppchen. Was sagt denn PC Games dazu? Ah ja, ja, sagen die. Die sagen Vampir Grill
im Video. Ach, irgendwie gibt es keine gescheiten Games, die mich jucken. Das ist... Das sackt
er. Monopoly ist noch schlimmer. Die schaffen alles verbuggt raus zu bringen. Jetzt fehlt
bloß noch, dass es in-game Uno gibt. Dass sie das so verkaufen, so nach dem Motto, kostenloser
Content-Patch für alle unsere treuen Spieler. Jetzt könnt ihr Uno spielen in Fallout mit
euren besten Freunden und nur die Fallout-Edition. Hast du dich eigentlich entschieden, Webinterface?
Ja oder nein? Ja, wahrscheinlich mache ich ein Webinterface, einfach, dass ich es ordentlich
im Stream einplanten kann und dass ich die Sachen abhaken kann. In Fallout Monopoly,
aber eher in einer Offline-Variante gibt es das, oder? Habt ihr das Drama mitgekriegt
damals, wo Fallout 76 rausgekommen ist? Also, wann kam das raus? Vor einem Dreivierteljahr
oder so. Mit dieser Cola-Flasche. Oder dem... Oder dem... Was war das mit dem Rucksack oder
so? Was war mit dem Rucksack? War das eine Tasche oder ein Rucksack? Ey, das ist so unglaublich
dämlich auch wieder gewesen, was sie da getrieben haben. Die Nuka-Cola, genau. Vor allem der
Witz ist ja... Ja, stimmt, eher. So was kann jeder mitkriegen. Vor allem der Witz war ja,
dass die Nuka-Cola im offiziellen Shop viel besser ist, als die Nuka-Cola, die du als
Pre-Order kaufen kannst. Oder als... Nee, nicht... Was war? Collector's Edition oder so, wo das dabei war.
Und da haben sie auch wieder richtig verkackt, ey. Richtig hängen geblieben. Aber die haben
das komplette Spiel so krass, so unglaublich verkackt, ey. Was, doch? So gesehen..net,
Piek. Piek hieß das da. Die Windows-Suche ist auch Mist. Hab's doch genau gesehen, hier.
.peak. Warum findet er es nicht, wenn ich Pieksuche? Warum? Warum nicht? Das ist so
eindeutig Piek. Was ist das für eine Suche, die nix findet? Diet, ja. Jetzt, wenn's einem
einmal aufgefallen ist, kann man's nicht mehr unseen machen. Was ist passiert mit deinem Pie?
Der DHL sagt, in Zustellung. Aber er ist, er kommt nicht. Wahrscheinlich wird das irgendwann
demnächst aktualisieren und sagen, ja, konnte heute nicht zugestellt werden, morgen. Oder aber,
sie haben es bei einem Nachbar abgegeben, haben es nirgendwo reingeschrieben und mir auch keine
Karte in Briefkasten geschrieben und mein Nachbar wundert sich schon, warum ich sie nicht abholen
kann. Hast du Statusmeldung nochmal aktualisiert bei DHL? Nö. Aber ich bin nicht oft im Stream.
Ist jetzt eh egal. Jetzt macht es dann doch keinen Unterschied mehr. Oder habt ihr schon
Steamsale was gekauft? Oder findet ihr auch nix? Fragt doch mal den Nachbarn, ne, der hätte
schon was gesagt. Nee, der Nachbar hätte schon was gesagt. Der Briefkasten liegt nicht, da hab
ich ja reingeguckt. Leute, wisst ihr was? Das mit dem Raspberry wird heute garantiert
nix mehr und selbst wenn der jetzt noch kommen sollte, was ich nicht mehr glaube, ist zu
spät, weil ich morgen wieder 5.45 Uhr aufstehen muss. Ich gehe jetzt pennen. Übrigens weiß
ich, ich gehe jetzt off oder in einer Stunde pennen und mal gucken, ob es irgendwas gibt,
was wir hosten können. Gibt es irgendwas, was wir hosten können? Irgendeinen von den
Leuten, die ich hier, du folgst, folge ich denn. Ist egal, ja der hat eindeutig zu wenig
Zuschauer mit 8.000, 9.000. Und die bisschen kleineren gucken. Cyrus könnten wir hosten.
Weil mich ehrlich gesagt Autochess nicht sonderlich interessiert euch wahrscheinlich
auch nicht, denke ich mal. Irgendwie find ich grad nix. Ok Leute, ähm, ich hab jetzt
einen. Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen. Wir sehen uns das nächste Mal. Bis denn, CU.